Alpha zero is a game playing algorithm
that uses artificial intelligence and
machine learning techniques to learn to
play board games at superhuman levels in
this machine learning course from Robert
Forster you will learn how to create
Alpha Zero from scratch
thank you for tuning in in this video we
are going to rebuild Alpha 0 completely
from scratch using Python and The Deep
learning framework pytorch Alpha 0 was
initially developed by deepminds and it
is able to achieve magnificent
performance in extremely complex board
games such as go where the amount of
liquid bot positions is actually
significantly higher than the amount of
atoms than our universe so not only is
this very impressive just from an AI
standpoint on but additionally to that
the machine Learning System of alpha
zero learns all of this information just
by playing with itself and moreover the
various domains in which this algorithm
can be used are almost Limitless so not
only can this algorithm also play chess
and shogi in a very impressive way but
the recent Alpha tensor paper that was
also published by deepmind showed that
Alpha 0 can even be used to invent novel
algorithms inside of mathematics
so together we will first of all
understand how this algorithm works and
then we will build it from ground up and
train and evaluated on the games of
Tic-tac-toe and Connect 4 so that you
will also understand how flexible Alpha
0 really is when it comes to adapting it
to various domains so let's get started
okay great so let's start with the brief
overview of the alpha zero algorithm so
first of all it is important that we
have two separate components and on one
hand we have the save play part right
here and yeah during this phase our
Alpha 0 model basically plays with
itself in order to gather some
information about the game and while we
play with ourselves we also generate
data and this data will then be used in
The Next Step during training so in this
training phase right here which is say
the second component we like to optimize
our model based on the information it
gained while playing with itself
and then next we basically want to
fulfill the cycle and then use this
optimized model to play with itself
again
so if the idea is essentially to repeat
the cycle n number of times until we
have yeah reached an array Network so a
model right here that is capable of
playing a certain game better than any
human could because it just played with
itself use the information again to
optimize yeah itself and then play with
itself again basically and then we just
like to repeat that
so in between these two components we
have this Alpha 0 model right here which
is just in Array Network
and now let's look at this scenery
Network more closely so let's see how
this actually is architectured so
basically we take the state SCS input
and for the case of tic-tac-toe for
example the state would just be bot
position
um so just turn two numbers
and then we once we have the state yes
input we receive a policy and the value
as output so the policy here is this
distribution and for each action
basically it will tell us how promising
this action would be based on this state
we have received here as input so we'll
basically tell us where to play based on
the state right here
so this is the policy and then the value
is just a float and it will basically be
a measure telling us how promising the
state itself is for us as a player to be
in
so maybe a concrete example that make
might make all of this easier to
understand is something we have down
below here
so
here for the state we just take in this
position and remember that we are player
X in this case
and yeah if you're familiar with the
roots of tic-tac-toe you should see that
we should play down here because
um yeah then we would have three x's on
the lowest Road and yeah we would win
the game so if our model also
understands how to play this game then
we would like to receive a policy
looking some word like this where
basically the highest bar right here
is also this position uh down below that
would basically help us to win the game
so yeah this is how the policies should
look like and for the value we can see
that this state is quite nice for us as
a player because we can win here so we
would like to have a very high value so
yeah in this case the value is just a
float and the range of negative 1 and
positive one so we would like to have a
value that is close to positive one
because this state is quite optimal
okay now we uh yeah looked at how the
general architecture is built and how
the model is built but next we want to
understand the self play and the
training part more in depth so before we
do that you should also understand what
a Monte Carlo tree search is because
that is vital for self-play and the
general algorithm
so the Monte Carlo research is this
search algorithm right here and it will
take a state on our case a block
position as input
and then we find the action that looked
most promising to us
and this algorithm gets this information
by just as for declaring a root node at
the initial state right here
and then by building up this tree into
the future
so just like we can see right here
so basically the idea is that we create
these nodes into the future
right here and we get these notes by
just taking actions that lead us to the
Future
so this note right here for example is
just the place we arrive at when we take
this action one
based on this initial State at our root
note
so each node first of all the state like
S1 in this case
and so S3 right here would just be the
state we get when we first follow play
action one based on this initial State
and then when we would play action 3
based on this state right here
so having these actions after each other
basically
and then additionally to the state each
node also stores this variable W and W
is just the total number of wins
that we achieved when we played in this
direction into the future
so basically when we took action one
initially and arrived at this node we
were able to win three times when we
walked into the future even further
so
next to this variable we also have this
n variable right here and N is just the
total visit count so basically the total
number of times that we went into this
direction so here we can say that we
took action one four times
and out of these four times we were able
to win three times right
so after we have basically built up a
tree like this and we can then find the
action that looks most promising to us
and the way we do this is by looking at
the children of our root node so these
two notes right here
and then for each node we can calculate
the winning ratio so here we can say
that this node one three out of four
times while this node one one out of two
times and then we can say that you know
what this node right here has a higher
winning ratio and thus it looks more
promising to her to us
and because of that we can also say that
action one looks more promising than
action 2 because this action was the one
that even led us to this note here in
the first place so basically the result
of this tree right here that we got at
this time would be that action one
should be the action we we would like to
play
and then we could just use this
information to uh say you know what in
our actual game of tic-tac-toe for
example we now want to use this action
right here
so this is great but now the question
becomes how can we even build up a tree
like this and also how do we get the
information whether we win at this given
position or not right
so the way we come up with all of uh
this data right here is basically by
walking down all of these four steps for
a give number of iterations
so at the beginning we like we are in
our selection phase
and uh during selection we basically
walk down our tree
but we walk down our tree until we have
reached the so-called Leaf node so a
leaf node is a node that could be
expanded even further
um into the future so one example of a
leaf node would be this note right here
because you can see that we have only
one child as this note but actually we
could also expand in this direction if
we say that for each node there are
always two possible ways in which you
could expand in this example right here
so this is a leaf node and then also
this would be a default right here
because this node doesn't have any child
right and then also we can say that this
node also is the leaf node because it
only has one side right here but we
could still expand it in this direction
so yeah these are Leaf nodes for example
where these aren't any lymph nodes
because yeah this one already has two
children and this one also has two
children already
so yeah this is basically how selection
looks like
but now the question also becomes
um when we walk down which direction we
should pick right so when we just start
at the top we now have to decide whether
we want to walk down in this direction
or whether we want to walk down in this
direction right here basically the way
of finding out the direction we choose
when working down
is by taking the direction or the child
right here that has the highest UCB
formula like this
so while this might look a bit complex
in reality we just take the child but
um tends to win uh more often while also
trying to take a child that has been
visited at just a few number of times
relatively right
so on one hand we when we maximize this
formula we want to take the check with
the highest winning ratio
and also
um want to take the child that has
relatively few visits compared to this
large n which is just the total number
of visits for the parent
so if we would calculate the UCB formula
for B both of these nodes right here we
can see that the UCD formula here is
higher because this node has been
visited uh less often right and because
of that we would like to work in this
direction right here okay so during
selection we can now say that we walk
down in this direction right here
and now we have arrived at this node so
first of all we have to check if we
worked out walk down further or if we
have in fact reached the leaf node and
now we can say let's see that we have
which Leaf node right here right because
we could still expand in this direction
so we could still have a child right
here and because of that we actually
skip to the next phase of the MCTS and
that is the expansion phase
so right here in expansion we want to
create a new node and dependent to our
tree
so I will just create this node right
here and now we call it give it the
state as 7. then we can say that we took
the action A7
to get to this UD created node right
here
and at the beginning this node should
have a winning count of zero and also a
visit count of zero so I'm just going to
declare W7 right here and also in seven
like this
and both of them should just be equal
to zero at the beginning right because
we have just created this node and added
it to our tree but we have never been
there chilly
so now we can say that we further worked
down here to the node we have just
created
and so now we have also finished this
expansion phase right here
and next we have arrived at this
simulation phase
and here the idea is basically to play
randomly into the future until we have
reached a state uh where the game is
over right so we want to play into the
future until the game is finished
and
basically here we can just say we play
using random actions so we just play
randomly and finally we have just
reached this node right here and yeah
here the game is over
so this is the simulation phase and now
when we have reached this terminal a
node basically we then have to check
whether we have won the game or we have
lost or Draw has occurred so in this
concrete case we actually have one
and with that we can also finish the
simulation phase
so just finally now we have arrived at
the back propagation phase
and here we like to get this information
from our simulation and then we want to
give this information all the way up to
our parents until we have reached the
root note
so here because we have won the game
actually and during back propagation we
can
um first of all higher the number of
wins for this node right here so we can
say that we have one one time actually
then we can also hire the total number
of visits so here we have visited this
node one time and we have one in this
case
and because we want to back propagate
all the way up we can now also say that
here for this note and the number of
wins now is two
so the number of points we got when we
walk in this direction okay
and then also the total number of visits
should now be three
because we have yeah visited it when we
select it inside in this direction
and now we can also back propagate uh
all the way to our root mode
and here we can just say that the
general visit count is seven and the
total number of wins would be five right
okay
so now this would be a whole iteration
of this MCTS process
and um yeah then if we would again
um choose an action and we would just
check the children of our route again
and again could just choose the action
based on the winning
amount of wins right here
so this is great uh let's also just have
an example where we start from at the
beginning so that you yeah might find it
easier to understand the search
algorithm as well
so again we want to perform these steps
right here so at the beginning we are
just in our selection phase so we want
to walk down until we have reached the
leaf node but here you can see that this
root node already is a leaf node right
so basically we can now move on to
expansion and create a new node right
here
so let's say that we just create
this node right here
by taking action one
and then we will arrive at State one
here's when
then we can say that at this node that
we have just created the total number of
wins
right now should just be zero
and also the visit count should just be
zero
and so we have
W1 and N1 just created right here
and yeah both of them can just equal a
zero like this
so now we have also finished the
expansion part for the first iteration
and next comes the simulation part right
so we have worked in this way basically
right here
and now we want to simulate into the
future just by taking these random
actions so let's write this right here
and
now we have reached a terminal node
and now we have to check whether we have
won or lost or a rule is occurred again
so in this case we can just say that we
have one again
so because of that we actually can act
propagate now
and in back propagation we can say that
the number of wins here is one
with either this account being one as
well
and then we can do the same for our root
node right here so we can just say that
the number of wins for our root node is
also one
and the this account of our root node is
also works well
so now that we have finished with this
iteration I'm just going to clean
everything up here
foreign
and we can move on to the next iteration
right
so again we started selection and we
walk down until we have reached the
refund
but again we can see that our root node
actually still is the leaf node so let's
just expand this direction now
and here we will just give us action 2
and we will arrive at state 2.
and here again we have to set the total
number of wins to zero
so
W2 should be equal to zero sorry this
also S2
and then the visit count so N2 should
all also equal zero right here
so let's write N2 equals zero as well
so let's do it like this
and yeah now basically we walk in this
direction right here and next we can do
simulation again
so let's simulate all the way down until
we have reached the terminal node
and in this case we can say that we have
actually lost the game
so when I propagate all the way up I
will only increase the visit count right
here
so the physical should now be one but
the total number of wins should still
stay the same being zero because we have
lost here when we simulate it
so because of that when we back
propagate to our root mode we should
also only increase the visit count while
leaving the total number of wins the way
it was earlier
so let's also finish up with this
iteration right here
and
now we can move on to the next iteration
so first of all we want to do selection
again so we want to walk down until we
have reached the leaf node and now our
root node is fully expanded so we have
to calculate the UCB score for each of
our children right here and then we have
to select the child that has the highest
qcb score right
so when we calculate the UCB score for
both of them we can see that the UCB
score here is higher because we have won
the game in this case so we just walk
down this direction right here
and now uh basically we can move on to
expansion so let's expand in this
direction here
so let's create this new node right here
and appended to our tree and we took
action three actually when we expanded
in this direction and then the state
here should also be S3 because of that
and now again we can declare this total
number of points W so W3 and the visit
count n three
and both of them should just equal zero
at the beginning so let's
set them to zero
and now again we can
perform this
basic can perform some new simulation
again
so we walk down in this direction right
here
and yeah
so now let's do simulation
and when we do that we just arrived at
this terminal node again
and again we can now see that in this
case we have just lost the game after
just playing randomly
and because of that when we back
propagate we only want to increase the
visit count right here
we're not changing the total number of
wins
so let's set the this account to two as
well
and
then we can set
the visit count to three
okay
so this is this situation right here
great
um so now we can just
also clean all of this up right here
and then
we can move on
so next uh when we want to keep doing
this process right here we again have to
do selection right so now we have to
again calculate the UCB formula for both
of these values right here
and here we can see that
the UCB formula actually gives us a
higher results for this node just
because of the visit count that is lower
right here
so when we
now walk in this direction
we again have to check if we have
reached the leaf node or not so here we
have just reached the leaf node
so because of that we move to expansion
and create this new node right here and
this should just be equal to S4 then so
we can say that we took action 4 right
here
and then again the W and the this
account
um
should be set to zero
I'm sorry 100 color
so
W4
and and for you
being our number of wins and our visit
count
and let's set them to zero meters
okay so now we also walk in this
direction right here
and again after
um expansion we can now move to
simulation so when we move here
um begins terminal and in this case we
can just say that a draw has occurred
and in what in case of a draw we just
would like to add 0.5 to the total
number of wins because no players one
here or no one has one so um
because of that and we
pack propagate here first of all we can
increase the visit count
and then let's set the
number of wins to 0.5
and then up here we can set the wizard
counter to
and again we told the number of wins
should be 0.5
and when we back propagate all the way
up to our root nodes then we have
the total number of visits as being
formed and our
um so the number of wins should be 1.5
so this is just a an example of how the
multicabit research might actually look
when you just start at the beginning and
actually you can repeat
the cycle for just a set number of
iterations and you set this number
manually at the beginning
and alternatively you could also set the
time and during this time you would just
perform as many iterations as you can
but yeah in this case for example you
could just stop it for iterations but in
practice you might run for a thousands
of iterations
okay so now we can also look at the way
how our Monte colored research changes
when we adapt it to this General Alpha
zero algorithm
so there are two key changes that have
been made here so the first thing is
that we also want to incorporate the
policy that was gained from our model
into the search process right and
especially we want to add it to the
selection phase right here and we can do
this by incorporating it into this
updated UCB formula so this way you see
this P of I heart rate here so basically
when we select the child and we want to
take the
yeah children with the highest OCD
formula then we will also look at the
policy that was assigned to it from its
parent perspective so remember that the
policy is just this distribution of
likelihoods and basically for each
child when we expanded we would also
store this policy likelihood at the
given position
um here for the node as well
and because of that we then also tend to
select children more often that were
assigned a high policy by its parent
right so this way our model can guide us
through the selection phase inside of
our Monte Carlo research so yeah this is
the first key change here so just
generally this updated UCB formula right
here
and then for the next change we also
want to use the information of the value
that we got from our neural network and
we can use this information by first of
all completely getting rid of this
simulation phase yeah right here so we
don't want to do this random rollouts
into the future anymore until we have
reached the terminal state but rather we
will just use the value that we got from
our neural network when it basically
evaluated a certain State and this value
will then be used for back propagation
right so this way we use both the policy
for our selection and the value for our
back propagation of our neural network
because of that we know that our Monte
Carlo research will approve drastically
when we also have a model that
understands how to play the game so this
way at the end uh we then have a better
search with a better model that can even
create a much better model right so we
can this uh yeah keep the cycle up as
well okay so
there's also just a small change uh here
as well uh just a minor one and remember
that when we get policy from our neural
network we immediately get this
distribution right with the
probabilities for each potential child
and because of that it's much more
convenient now to expand an oil possible
directions during the expansion phase so
we won't only create one new node but
rather all of the possible nodes that we
can yeah expand on right
so this is just a minor change and so in
order to make this easier to understand
we can just do some iterations here on
the Whiteboard together so yeah this way
it might be easier to fully understand
how this multicolored research is
adapted so first you might also see here
that we also store this policy
information here inside of our node
and yeah this would just be the
probability that was assigned to it from
its parent right and for the root node
we just have no policy probability
because we also have no parent for other
nodes we will also store this policy
here instead of our nodes
okay so let's start with an iteration
here so first of all we want to walk
down until we have which relief mode and
here we can already see that our root
node is in fact additional because we
can say expanded in these two directions
here so because of that we will then
move to the next step right here which
is the expansion phase and here we will
actually create our new nodes
so now when we expand we also want to
get a policy and value from our neural
network so because of that I will first
of all write p and then value
equals
just calling our neural network it's the
state of our root nodes
and let's say this policy right here
will just be
0.6 for the first child
and then maybe 0.4 for the second child
and let's say that this value so the
estimation of how good this state of our
root models is just 0.4 here
okay so now when we expand we will
create this these two
new nodes right here
so
that these two and here we have action
one right
and here we have action 2.
so because of that we also have state
one here and we have state two right
here so now we can also add the number
of wins the visit count and the policy
information to our notes right here so
first of all I will create this W1 and
set the equal to zero then I will create
this n one and set that also equal to
zero and now we have this policy
probability one and this should be equal
to the policy for action one and here
the purpose fraction one is just 0.6 so
yeah the policy here should be
0.6 because of that
so now we can also add the information
here to the other side so let's first of
all set the number of wins or
the value later on here zero this way
for W2 and let's set n to
0 as well and the policy probability
for the this child right here should now
be equal to 0.4 right
um
like this
okay so now we have expanded here
and we skip this step here so now we
move to the back propagation step
and here we just want to back propagate
this value right here
so we will just do this by
um
yeah just adding it right here so
basically in this case it doesn't matter
much for our root notes but maybe it's a
nice information so we can just add 0.4
here and then because of that also
change we visit come to one point
okay so this was one iteration and now
we can move on to the next iteration so
I will just clean this up
okay so now again we want to walk down
until we reach a leaf node so now we
have to decide between those two
children right
and for each we have to calculate the
UCB formula and then also we were just
walk down in the direction where the UCB
formulas the highest
right so when we calculate this UCB
formula we will see that no longer can
we
basically get the winning yeah um
winning probability here because we have
a visit count that is equal to zero So
currently the way this is implemented we
get we would get a yeah division by zero
error so here we have to make sure that
we will only check for the winning
probability if we have this account that
is larger than zero so because of that
oh it just set that in Brackets right
here so we will only check for this if
we have a this account that is larger
than zero under other cases we will just
mask it out so we will just check for
this part right here okay so now we can
I find out the child where this value is
the highest and we can see that we would
just pick this child right here because
it has the higher policy probability and
because of that it's UCB formula will
also be higher so because of that we
would just walk in this direction right
here
so now we have reached a leaf node here
and we would like to expand this node
here
so let's expand in these two directions
so first of all this should be action
three
and this should be action 4 right here
so when we create this new States we
have state three
and we have state 4 like this
okay so now
again we also have to calculate the new
policy and the new value so we will get
this
policy and this value
by calling our neural network f
with this state here so S1
because yes this is the position we have
walked down to and from here we want to
find out what the policy would be for
these children and also what the value
would be for this note directly so let's
say that the policy here is just
zero point
five and 0.5 okay
and let's say that this value right here
is just 0.1
so now
um first of all we can also add this
information here to our nodes again so
let's first of all set W 4 equal to 0
and we can say n for equal to zero
and then policy probability 4 should be
equal to 0.5
and then here we also have here W3 which
should just be zero
and we have N3 which should also be zero
and then we have also our policy
probability three here and this should
be equal to 0.5 and we can read that
here
Okay so
yeah now we have expanded this to
Children right here
and I created them and sort the policy
information here and serve them so now
we want to back propagate again so here
we will just use this value of 0.1 so
actually we will add 0.1 here
and we will raise this visit count by
one
so let's change that one right here and
remember that we want to back propagate
all the way up to our root note so here
we will change the value so w 0 here to
0.5 so also add 0.1 to it and then we
will just erase this number of physical
by one as well so it will be two
afterwards
so yeah this is just this updated tree
after these two iterations but yeah
again if we would predict this we would
just first of all walk down until we
have reached reached a leaf node then we
would expand and use the policy
um here when we store the policy
information in the new children and then
we would just use the value for back
propagating up all the way in our trade
to our root mode right so yeah these are
just the smart changes that have been
added to our Monte Carlo research
great so now that you know what a
multi-colored research is and how we
adapt our multicolored research in
during our Alpha zero algorithm we can
actually move to the self-play part
right here
so basically during self-play we just
yeah play games with ourselves from the
beginning to end and so we start by just
getting this initial state right here
with this which is just a completely
blank state
and yeah we also are assigned to a
player and then based on this state
player
um yeah position we perform a
multi-colored research
and yeah this Monty College research
will then give us this distribution as a
return which is equal to the visit count
distribution of the children of our root
node right
and once we have this distribution we
then would like to sample an action of
this distribution
so in this case right here we for
example
sample this action which is highlighted
here because yeah it turned out to be
quite promising during during our Monte
colored research
so once we have sampled this action we
want to act based on it so we play here
basically as player X and then yeah we
move to the next state and we also
switch the player around so that we are
now player Circle or player o
and we have this state basically as
import at the beginning
and then again we want to perform this
multicolored research right here
and we gain this MCTS distribution then
we just yeah sample one action out of it
we play based on this action and then we
can basically change the perspective
again so that we are now a player X
and we basically yeah continuously
perform a Monte Carlo tree search sample
an action out of it play uh this action
right here and then change the
perspective so that we are now the other
player or the opponent
and we do that until we actually have
reached the terminated state so once a
player has won or a draw has occurred
and yeah so when this is the case we
want to store all of this information we
gained while playing
um to the training data so let's first
look how this information is structured
so
basically for each state
we also want to store the MCTS
distribution
and then we also need to find out the
reward for the given State the reward is
equal to the final outcome for the
player that we are on this given state
so basically in this example right here
x won the game so that means that for
all states when we were player X we want
the final reward or final outcome be
equal to one and in other cases when we
were player o and we want the reward to
be negative one because we lost the game
so basically that means that
you know what we want this game as play
X right here so we might just guess that
this state also is quite promising
because yeah this that it led us to win
the game eventually so this is why we
turn change this reward to positive one
here when we apply X and this is also
the reason why we change the reward to
negative one when we are player
um player o here so this
um combinations of the state the MCTS
distribution and the reward will then be
stored as two bits to our training data
and then we can later use these
um for training right in order to
improve our model
so this is great but now we have to
understand how training works so yeah
let's look at this right here
so at the beginning we just take a
sample from our training data and yeah
you should know now that the sample is
the state the MCTS distribution and pi
and the reward Z right here
then we will use the state S as the
input for our model
then we will get this policy and this
value out as a return
and now for training The Next Step
basically is to minimize the difference
between the policy p and the MCTS
distribution at the given State pi
on one hand and then we also want to
minimize the difference of our value V
here and the final reward or final
outcome Z we sampled from from our
trending data and the way we can
minimize the difference
basically in a loss is first of all by
having a mean squared error between
the reward and the value here and then
by also having this multi-target cross
entropy loss between our MCTS
distribution pi and our policy P right
here then we also have some form of a
true regularization at the end but yeah
so essentially we want to have this loss
right here and then we want to minimize
the uh the loss by back propagation
and this way we actually update the
weights of our model Theta right here
and we also thus get a model that better
understands how to play the game and
that has been optimized then we can use
this optimized model to again play with
itself in order to gain more information
in order to train again and so on right
um so this is however zero is structured
and now we can actually get to coding
so let's actually start by programming
Alpha zero so first of all we're going
to build everything inside of a jupyter
notebook since the interactivity might
be nice for understanding the algorithm
and also this might help you if you want
to use Google collab for example to use
quiz gpus to train a physical more
efficiently
and we will start everything just by
creating a simple game of tic-tac-toe
and then we will build the Monte colored
research around it and after we have
gone so far we will eventually build
Alpha 0 on top of the multi-colored
research we had previously and then we
will expand our portfolio to connect
four as well
and not only should this be easier to
understand
but it should also show how flexible fs0
really is when it comes to solving
different environments or board games in
this case
so for Tic-tac-toe we want to use numpy
as a package
so we're just import numpy
SMP right here and if you are wondering
my version currently is this right here
so let's just create a class of
tic-tac-toe
and simple in it
[Music]
and we first of all want to have a row
count which equates three if a column
count as well should also be three
and then we also need the action size
and the action size is just the amount
of rows multiplied with the amount of
columns
so save dot row count time set of column
count
[Music]
so that's great and now we can write a
method to get our initial state
so this is what we will call at the
beginning
[Music]
and
at the beginning the states just
full of zeros so we will just return in
Period zeros
and we shape here is
the row count for the number of rows and
the column count for the number of
columns
[Music]
and next we also want a method that will
give us the next state after action
has been taken
so
we write get next state here and as
input we want the previous state the
action and also the player
so the action itself will be just an
integer between 0 and 8 where 0 will be
the corner uplift and eight will be the
corner done right
so actually we want to encode this
action into a row and a column so that
we can use it inside of our numpy array
so the way we do this is that we Define
the row as
the action divided by the column count
but we will use an integer division here
so
we will get no floats
and then for the column we can use the
modal law
of the action and the column count as
well so
if our action would be 4 for example
then our row would be a Ford integer
division by three which we just return
one
and our column would be 4 modulo 3 which
is also one so we would have Row one and
then column one as well so the middle of
our board which is exactly what we want
so then we can set the state at the row
at the given column
to the player we had as input
and let's also return the state
so our code is more readable
so that's awesome and next we also want
a method that will tell us what moves
are actually legal so these are just
um
the most weather field is equal to zero
so let's write a method get valid moves
[Music]
also gives a status input and then we
can just return
um state DOT reshape
negative one so we've flattened up the
state and then we can check if the state
is equal to zero and this will give us a
Boolean array back so true or false but
it's quite helpful if we have integers
here so I will
turns the type to np.u and 8 so unsigned
integers
and yeah that's awesome so now we also
want a method that will tell us if a
player has won after he took or he acted
in a certain way so let's also write a
method for that so just Dev check win
[Music]
and here we want the state and then
action
so let us first get the row again so we
just say action integer division self
dot column card
[Music]
and let's also get the column here
um let's
so now we can also get the player that
played in the given position and the way
we do the this is just that we check
the state at the row of the column so
basically we turn this expression here
and the other way around
um and actually in tic-tac-toe there are
four different ways in which you could
win a game so first of all you could
have three in a row like this but you
could have three in a column like this
or three in this diagonal or three in
this diagonal right here and we want to
check for all of these four conditions
and if one of them turns out to be true
then we will return true as well and
none of them are true then we're just
returned for it so let's write out all
of these Expressions right here
so first of all we can just check if
there are three in a row
so we will use mp.sum of the state of
the given row and all of the columns
inside of that row and we want to check
if that sum right here is equal to the
player times
the column count
and yeah
and then we can also check whether there
are three and a column like this so we
just use np.sum of state of
all of the rows for a given column
and then again we check if that equals
player time set of column count
oh row count in this case
I mean let's be more flexible here
and that's great so now we want to check
for this diagonal and the way we can do
this is by using the NP dot diag method
so I put up the documentation right here
and if we would have an array like this
which we also want to have for
Tic-tac-toe and then we can use this
diag method right here to get the values
from this diagonal so let's use this
choice to check that someone has one so
we use mp.sum of np.diac of state and we
check if that's equal to player times
save.row count or safe.columncard in
this case it doesn't matter because you
can only get this fully diagonal of
broken and column count is the same
and next we also want to get this
opposite diagonal right here and there
is no way to do it with the normal diet
method but we can just flip our state
and then use this old diet method again
and since our state is flipped it would
be as if our diac itself is flipped if
that makes sense so we can just use all
mp.sum of NP dot diac of np.flip
of the state let's just say x is equal
to zero so we flip like this and then we
can take the opposite diode which is
what we want
so I also check if it equals player
times save dot account
[Music]
so awesome
um and next we always want to check if
the
if there has been a draw so
um if the game terminated in any other
way
and since this might also be a scenario
where we want to stop the game so let's
just write a new method get value and
terminate it
[Music]
and we want to State and an action
and first of all we will check if check
win is true in this case so if check
when or save to check when
[Music]
of state of action
then we'll just return one for the value
and true for terminated
and then we can also check if there has
been a draw and that we know that there
has been a draw of the amount of valid
moves to zero so we can just take the
sum of the valid moves and check if
that's zero so I say
if NP dot sum
of safe.getwell moves
of the given state
[Music]
equals zero then we just return
0 for the value since no one has one
again and we will also turn return true
for terminated and in all other cases
the game must continue so let's just
return zero and fights
awesome so now we got a working game of
Tic-tac-toe and additionally would also
want to write a method to change the
player since that might be different for
different board games so let's just
write a method get opponent
[Music]
and
yeah take a player's input and then we
just
return the negative player so if our
initial player would be negative one we
would return one end of our initial
player would be one then we would just
return to a negative one
so that's great and now we can test our
game we built right here so I just say
tick tock toe liquid stick
attack top
then I just say player equals one and I
say State equals Tic Tac Toe dot get
initial state
awesome so then let's just buy it the
while loops
let's just say y true we'll print the
state right here then we want to get our
valid moves so we know where to play so
I just say Well it moves equals
tic-tac-toe
dot get rid of moves
of this state we have currently
and we can also print it so I just say
valid moves
and
you know what let's print the valid
moves in a more readable performance
currently we only have zeros and one but
we actually want to get the position
where we can play so I just create this
array right here and I say e for e in
range
[Music]
and then we can just say Tic Tac Toe dot
action size
So currently we get all the indices for
the possible actions
and then we want to check if the indices
itself is valid so we say if valid moves
of I
equals one right so we want to get all
of these indices and this can just be
printed out like this
and then we want to get an action so the
action will just be an input that would
be casted with an integer
and let's just
um write out the player
like this
um
and get the action right here
so then we want to check if the action
is valid
so we'll say
if valid moves
of action liquids zero and with just say
print
um
action not valid
and we will continue so we'll ask again
this week
and in other cases we want to move so we
create a new get a new state and the
news that will be created by calling
tic-tac-toe dot get next state
[Music]
and
we want to give the old set the action
that the players should
[Music]
um great
um so then we can check if the game has
been terminated
so we just say value is terminal equals
tic-tac-toe dot get
[Music]
value and terminated
and then we want to give the state and
the action is input
and then we say if this terminal
print the state so we know where we are
and then we will check if value equates
one
and then we'll say player has one so
just say player
so
one or negative one for the player
and in all other cases
um we can just print that there has been
a draw
great and then we also want to break our
while loop so
we can end the game
and in all other cases if the game
continues we also want to flip the
player
um so we just say player equals Tick
Tock toe dot get opponent
of player
so nice it should be working so let's
test this out so here are the valid
moves so it's looking nice so let's just
pick zero for starters let's see nice
okay we played here so we apply a
negative one now so let's just play four
at play Zero we can just say eight Okay
negative one one for example
play Zero I'd say two and play negative
one and just say seven and nice we see
here we got
three negative ones inside of this
column right here and thus we get the
result that plan negative one has one
perfect so now since we have cut our
game of detect already we can actually
build the multi-colored research around
it
so let's just create a new cell right
here
and then we want to have a class for our
multi-colored research so I'm just going
to call that MCTS for now
and then we have our init here
and we want to pass on a game so
tic-tac-toe in this case and then also
some arguments so these are just hyper
parameters for our multicolored research
so inside of our init we can say
self.game equals game and safe.args
equals args
and then below we'll Define our search
method and this is what we'll actually
recall when we want to get our MCTS
distribution deck
so let's just write their search
and for the search we want to pass a
status input
and inside here first of all we'd like
to define a root node
and then we want to do all of our search
iterations so for now we can write for
search in
range of
safe.ax num searches
[Music]
and then for each search we'd like to do
the selection phase
then the expansion fits
then the simulation phase and then the
back propagation phase
and then after we have done all of these
things for the given number of searches
we just want to return the visit count
distribution
and uh it's the distribution of visit
counts for the children of our root
notes so let's just say a return visit
counts
yeah at the end
yeah so that's the structure we have
inside of Harmony College research
and next we can actually define a class
for a node as well
that's right class node here and then
have our init again
and first of all we'd like to pass on
the game and the arguments from the MCTS
itself
and then also we want to have a state as
a note
and then a parent
but not all nodes have parents so for
the root note we can just write none
here as a placeholder and then we also
want to have an action taken but again
we have a placement of none
um
for the root note here as well
so inside of our init we can just say
surf.gaming quits games if dot arcs with
arcs
self.state with equal State and then
again search for parent equals parent
and serve.action taken liquid section
table
so next we also want to store the
children inside of our node so let's
write self.children equal it's just an
empty list so these are the children of
our node and then also we want to know
in which ways we could further expand
our node
so for example if the root node would
just be an initial State then we could
expand in all nine fields for a Tic Tac
Toe board and yeah we want to store this
information here so let's just say save
Dot
expand the moves
equals
game dot get valid moves of State at the
beginning then as we keep expanding here
we will also remove this expandable
States from our list here
and additionally to all of these
attributes we also want to store the
visit count and the various sum of our
nodes so that we can later perform our
UCB method and get the distribution back
at the end so let's say safe.viso
account with 0 at the beginning and save
the value sum should also equals zero
when we start
so yeah that's uh just the backboard or
the beginning structure of our node and
now we can Define our root node here
so let's say root equals node
and we have safe.game
save dot arcs and then the state we took
here's input
and the apparent and action can just
stay none then inside of our search we
just want to say node equals root at the
beginning
and next we want to do selection
so from the video you might remember
that we want to keep selecting downwards
the tree as long as our nodes are fully
expanded themselves
so
for doing so we should write a method
here that will tell us so def is fully
expanded
[Music]
and the node is fully expanded if there
are no expandable moves so that makes
sense and also if the number if there
are children right so
um if our node would be terminated you
obviously can't select past it because
the game has ended already
so let's say return
NP dot sum of safe Dot
expand
able moves
and
[Music]
that should be zero right and Len of
self.children
should be larger than zero so this way
we can check whether node is fully
expanded or not
so during our selection phase we can
just say while node is fully expanded
[Music]
foreign
and here we just want to select
downwards we say node equals node.select
so now we can clear this right here
and next we want to write a method that
will actually select down so I'm going
to write that here
and
the way selection works is that we will
Loop over all of our children as a node
and for each child we will calculate the
UCB score
and then additionally
at the end we will just pick the child
that has the highest UCB score
so for the beginning we can just write
best child liquids none since we haven't
checked any of our children yet
and then best UCB should just be
negative MP dot Infinity
[Music]
and then we can write for child
didn't save the children
[Music]
and then UCB equals self dot get UCP of
this child right here
and then we can check if UCB is larger
than best UCB
and if that is the case we say this
child should be child
and best USB should also equal UCB now
right and at the end we can just return
best chat here
[Music]
um so next we should actually write this
method right here we use for calculating
the UCB score
and
yeah we want to take a child yes it
would
and for the UCB score we first of all
have our Q value and the Q value should
be the likelihood of winning for a given
node
and then at the end we have our C which
is a constant that will tell us whether
we want to focus on exploration or
exploitation
and then at the end we have a math
square root and then we have a log at
the top
with the visit count of the parent and
then below we have the visit count of
the chart so we want to first of all
select notes that are promising from the
win likelihood perceived by the parent
and then also we want to select notes
that haven't been visited that often
compared to the total number of visits
so first of all we should Define the Q
value
and that
should generally be the visit sum of our
child divided by its visit count uh
sorry it's relative sum
so the value sum of our chart divided by
its wizard count
[Music]
and the way we implemented our game
would actually be possible to have the
negative values from
and generally we would like our Q value
to be in between the range of 0 and 1
because then we could turn it into a
probability
so um currently it's between negative
one and positive one so let's just add a
1 here and then at the end we can also
divide everything up by two
and now there's just one more thing we
could we should think about
and that is that actually
the Q value right here is what the child
thinks of itself and not how it should
be perceived as by the parent because
you should know that in tic-tac-toe the
child and the parent generally are
different players
so as a parent we would like to select a
child that itself has a very negative or
very low value
because as a player we would like to put
our opponent in a bad situation
essentially right so we want to switch
this around
and we do this by saying one minus our
old Q value here so if our child has a
now normalized value that is close to
zero then as a parent this actually
should give us a q value that is almost
1 because this is very good for us to
worked on the tree in a way that our
child is in a bad position
so now we can just return our UCB right
here so I'm just going to write Q Value
Plus safe.args of C
and then that should be multiplicated
with math.s square root
and we should also import that up here
so that we oh sorry
I like that
so that we can use it and inside of our
square root we have math.log
and here we have the visit count as a
node process so just save.visit count
and then we can divide everything up by
a chart of this account
[Music]
yeah so that should be it
and perfect
so now we actually have a working
selection method here and
now we can move on so
now we have moved down all the selected
down
um the tree as far as we could go and we
have reached the leaf node or a node
that is a terminal one so before we
would like to expand our Leaf node we
still have to check whether our node
will have finally selected here is the
terminal one or not
we can do this by writing value is
terminal
equals search dot game
dot get value and terminated
[Music]
and inside so we are referencing this
method right here
um so here we just want to write State
and H
is the input so we can take the state of
our node here we have selected and then
also The Last Action that was taken so
just no dot action take
and we still have to remember one thing
and that is
um that the note always gets initialized
this way so the action taken was the
action that was taken by the parent and
not this note itself so it was an action
that was taken by the opponent from the
notes perspective
so if we would actually have reached a
terminal node and if we would get the
result that yeah a player has one here
then the player who has one is the
opponent and not the player of the note
itself
so if we want to read this value here
from the notes perspective we would have
to change it around
so here inside of our game method we
should write a new method def get
opponent value
and here we can just say negative value
so if
from the parents perspective we have got
a one right here is a return and we
would like to turn it into a negative
one from the child's perspective because
it's the opponent that has one another
child itself
okay so let's use it right here so let's
say where you equates
safe.game dot get opponent value of the
old value
and we should also keep one thing in
mind and that is that we're using this
node.action taking method right here
right but actually at the beginning we
just have our simple root node and we
can see that the root node is not fully
expanded right because it has all
possible ways we could expanded on so we
will call this right here
immediately with our root note and the
way we initiated our root nodes
we still have action taken it's none
right and if we call this method right
here with action taken being none
um so we call this with action taking B
none and we'll move to check one with
action being none and then we will do
this expression right here and this will
just give an error so we have to say if
action equates none
[Music]
just return forwards right because for
the root note we always know that no
player has won since no player has
played yet so we can just leave it like
this
um perfect so now we're finished with
all of this and
next we want to check if this node is
terminal and then we code back propagate
immediately and if not then we would do
expansion and simulation so I'm writing
now here if is
if not is terminal
then we want to do this right here
and at the end we can just back
propagate right
okay so yeah now we can do expansion and
inside
well this if statement I can just write
no dig with no dot expand
and so we just like to return the note
that was created by expanding here and
then inside of our node class we can
write a new method that will do the
expansion job
so let's say Dev expand
[Music]
and okay that's
so the way expanding works is that we
sample one expandable move out of these
expandable moves we have defined up here
and then once we have sampled this move
for Action we want to create a new state
for our child we want to act inside this
state and then we want to create a new
node
um with this new Step we've just created
and then we append this node to our list
of children here so we can later
reference it inside of our select method
and yeah at the end we can just return
the chart that was created newly
so for now let's get an action here
and yeah we want to sample it from above
so let's use np.render.choice
so this will just pick a random value
out of a list
on numpy array and inside we can say
np.where
and then uh the condition is that
safe.expand
it will moves
should be equal to one right because the
way we programmed it all values that are
one actually legal and we could expand
on them and with mp.where you always
have to use the first argument you get
when using the method so yeah this
should work now so yeah we just first of
all check what moves are legal then we
usmp.where to get the indices
um of from all legal moves and then we
use np.random.choice to randomly sample
one indices and this legal NDC will then
be the action we got right
so that's great and now we also have to
make this move not uh expandable anymore
right since we're already sampled it so
we can say it's safe.expandable moves of
action
and that should just be zero here
nice so now we can create the state for
our chart and at the beginning we can
just copy our own state
now we would like to act instead of the
state of our chart so we can say child
state
equals
safe.game dot get next
state
so we reference this right here and then
we can use State action and player
so
let's move up again
so for State we have just child State
and for Action we have the action right
here and for the player we will use one
so you might have noticed that we
haven't even defined the player yet
which is weird right because for
Tic-tac-toe you have two players
obviously
but the way we will program our Monte
Carlo research is that we will never
change the player or never give the note
the information of the player but rather
we will always change the state of our
child so that it is perceived by the
opponent's player while the opponent's
player still thinks that he is player
one right even though so the parent that
the child both think that they are
player one but instead of changing the
player we flip this state around so we
turn all positive numbers into negative
ones and vice versa and this way
um we can actually create a child state
that has a different player but still
thinks it's player one so this just
makes the logic much more easy for our
game
and it also makes the code
um here valid for one player games even
so that's very nice so now we can say
child State equidsafe DOT game dot
change perspective
of child State and then the player
should be negative one right because in
tic-tac-toe when you change the
perspective
or when you create a child node you
always want to be the opponent
here so let's write a new method def Dot
change perspective
of the state
and of a player
and in tic-tac-toe we can just return
the state multiplied with the player so
like I said when we would change the
perspective to play a negative one so
two opponents then we would turn all
positive ones to negative ones instead
of our tic-tac-toe game
um so nice so now we have come here
and we have got on our child status
ready now so next we can just create the
child itself which is a new note so
let's say child equals node and up here
we can see that first of all we need the
game so it should just be saved.game
then save.ox
and then the state which is just a child
state
and for the parent we can choose
ourselves as a node and then for the
action taken we can use this action
right here we send it above
so let's just take that
and now we want to append this child to
our children so I'm saying I'm going to
say
safe.children.append child right here
and at the end of our method we can
return the child we have just created
so awesome that's the code finished here
so we have gotten this expansion part
done
and after we have expanded we want to do
simulation so from the video you might
remember that we formed these rollouts
and the way rollouts work is that we
just perform random actions until we
have reached a node that is terminal and
then we will look at the value so the
final outcome of this game so who won
essentially
and then we'll use this information who
won
um to back propagate basically right so
nodes where the player of the node
itself one of the randomly choosing
actions are more promising than
um the ones where the opponent one right
so yeah we use this for our back
propagation
so here we can just say value equals
note dot simulate
and then we obviously need to write a
simulate method up here
so let's do that for now so Dev simulate
of self
and first of all again we have to check
if this node that has just been expanded
this uh terminal one
so up here we just say value is terminal
equal itself.game dot get value and
terminate it
and inside we can again use self.state
and save dot action table
and we have to again flip this value
around to the opponent's perspective
because
um always when
notice one one it's not because of the
node itself but because of its parent
that has taken this action here so we
have to say
value equals save Dot Game dot get
opponent value of the value we have
gotten here
and yeah then we could just say if
this terminal
then we would like to return this value
up here
and in all other cases we now want to
perform our rollout so
in order to do that we can just say roll
out state
equaled self.state dot copy
[Music]
and then we say Roy odd player liquids
one at the beginning and here we're
actually going to use the player just
that's just because we need to find out
if the value we got at the end should be
perceived
by this get opponent Value method or not
when we use it to back propagate our
node uh it's value right here
so inside of our product we can say why
they're true
and then again we want to sample an
action like we did up here so first of
all we can say valid moves equals Dot
Game dot get when it moves of the raw
out state
[Music]
and then here we can write action
equates mp.random.choice
of np.where off valid moves
equals one
take the first one
yeah and yeah that should be our action
and now we can use that action to get
the next state so we can write raw out
States equals
and then we can say save.game dot get
next state
[Music]
and then again we use the word state
and the action here and then for the
player we'll use Royal player
[Music]
and after we have got now a new state we
have to check again whether this state
is terminal
so let's write value
equality save dot game
Dot
get
value
and terminate it
[Music]
and we just use this newly updated real
estate as input and also the action we
took
and now if this terminal is true we'd
like to return our value so let's write
that as an if statement
[Music]
for the value we again have to check
whether we were a player one when we won
the game or hit a terminal note
so we say if row out player with
negative one
then we would flip the value up so that
we don't get a positive return since the
opponent one and notes we as a note
so we can say that you include self Dot
Game dot get opponent value of value
and generally we can just return this
value here like we did up here above
so nice now in our other cases if we
haven't reached the terminal node
immediately we want to flip our play
around so we can say raw out player
equality save.game dot get
component
of the old old player
yep so that should be it
um so yeah now we can do simulation
after we have expanded
and the final step would now be to do
back propagation
and we can just write a new method here
so let's say no dot back prop type gate
and then we pass the value here as input
we have gotten either here or here
and we can write that here inside of our
node class so Dev back propagate
[Music]
and then take value here's input
so when we back propagate first of all
we want to add the value to our value
sum and then we want to add our Visa
card with just a one so count that up
and then we want to keep it propagating
up all the way to our root node
so let's write save dot value of sum
plus equals value
and then let's write safe.visit count
plus equals one
then when we back propagate up we again
have to remember that our parents is a
different player than us
so we should write value equals search
Dot Game dot get opponent value
of value here and then we say if parent
is not none
which is always true except for the root
note where we have this as our
placeholder
um then we're just going to say parent
dot back proper
gate that you write here
and that should be
so yeah we have this recursive back
propagate method
and that should be all we need for MCTS
so finally we have gotten all of the
results we have back propagated all of
our visit counts and values and so on so
now we would actually like to return the
distribution of visit counts
so to do that we should just
um
write a new variable action props so the
probabilities of uh which actions look
most promising and at the beginning that
should just be MP dot zeros and the
shape here can just be
the action size of our game so save.game
dot get
dot action size
so
for Tic-tac-toe just this one right here
and now we want to Loop over all of our
children again
so let's say for child and served or
children
and then we write action props at
child.action taken
and this probability should be equal to
the visit count of our child so let's
say child.visit count and that and now
um
we want to turn these into probabilities
and the way we do that is we're just
divided by its sum so that the sum will
be equal to 1.
and let's just write mp.sum of action
cross right here and then we can return
this
[Music]
so that's looking promising so let's
just absorb
and there is the inverted syntax here so
I just
should these should remove this here and
now that's working so let's test this
out and we can create a MCTS object here
inside of our test script we used for
the game
so let's write MCTS equals MCTS and for
the game we use tic-tac-toe
and now we still have to Define our
arguments so for C which we use in our
UCB formula
and we can just
roughly say that we want the square root
of 2 which is what you might use
generally
and then for the number of searches we
can set that to a thousand
[Music]
nice um so let's also pass on the arcs
here inside of our multi-colored
research
and then during our game first of all I
should remove that um
we should say that we only do all of
this so acting ourselves if we are
player one
[Music]
and in other cases so I take the toe
when player is negative one we want to
do a multi-colored research so we can
say MCTS props quits
mcts.search of State
but you should remember that we always
like to be player one here when we do
our multi-colored research so first of
all let's write neutral State liquids
and then we can say safe.game
dot change perspective and also not such
a game by Tick Tock toner yeah
um
and then we'll use this General State
here and for the player we can just set
a player which is here always negative
one so we always change the perspective
then instead of MCTS search we should
just use this Nutri State we have just
created
and that's great and now out of these
probabilities we want to sample an
action and to keep things easy we can
just sample the action that looks most
promising and the way we do that is by
using mp.arkmax
and this will just return the chart that
has been visited most number of times
and inside here we can use the props of
our MCTS
yep and that's just the action we have
here so let's test result to see if this
works
okay so we still have a problem here uh
also um for parent we need to use
self.parent
[Music]
and here I have a typo
and so
just want to say best child
[Music]
and here we don't want to use save to
Children obviously but the child
children of our root note so instead of
MCTS we can say
for child in root of children
so perfect so now we can see that this
multi-colored research moved here inside
the middle and now we as a player let's
play a bit here to check this out and we
can just play here MCT has played here
then we can say I will play seven and
now the LCT has played here and
from the roots of tic-tac-toe you know
that we're the MCTS has hit three
negative ones here instead of this row
here so it has one so nice so now we can
see that this MCTS is working with okay
so now that we have our Standalone
multicolored research implemented right
here
and we can now start with building the
neural network right so that we can then
later use the alpha zero algorithm in
order to train this model that can
understand how to play these given games
right
and before we start uh yeah with
building
um let me just briefly talk about the
architecture that we have for our neural
network
so yeah this is just a brief
visualization here
and first of all
we have this state right here that we
gave us give us input to our Android
network and yeah in our case this state
would just be a board position so for
example a board of tic-tac-toe right
here
and actually we encode the state so that
later we have these three different
planes next to each other like in this
image right here and actually we have
one plane for all of the fields in which
player negative one is played so where
these fields will then be turned to once
and or other fields would just be zeros
and then we also have a plane for all
the empty fields and this region then
between the ones or other fields being
zeros and then after this last plane for
other fields in which player positive
one played and yeah here again the these
fields will be turned to once and all
the other fields will be turned to zeros
so by having these three planes right
here it is easier for our Network to
basically recognize patterns and
understand how to play this game right
so essentially we encode our board game
position uh almost so that it looks like
an image afterwards right because we
have instead of these RGB planes we have
these planes for player positive one uh
player zero or empty fields and play a
negative one right
and because
we our state looks like an image we also
want to use neural network architecture
that works best for images right and so
because of that we have these
convolutionary blocks then inside of our
neural network right so first of all we
have this backbone right here and this
backbone will just be the main part of
owner Network
um where we do most of the computation
and here for the backbone like I said we
use these convolutional blocks
and we also use this resnet architecture
so the residual Network
and
this is just a research paper that
turned out to work really yeah well with
um understanding images
and here basically what this resonant
architecture does is that we have these
skip connections like this
so when we do the feed forward through
our backbone we won't just always update
the X by moving forward right but rather
we will also store this residual so
basically we store the x value or the
you know value that is passed through
and before we give it to our conf block
and then at the end the output will just
be the sum of the x value before conflog
and the x value after our conf block or
conf blocks and because of that our
model is much more flexible because it
could technically also mask out conf
blocks by not changing the X at all and
just using this residual skip connection
X right so here's also just an image
from the paper
so yeah generally the main idea is to
also store this x right here at this
position as a residual and then have the
skip connection later on so that the
output will be the output from the conf
blocks summed with the initial X so the
skip connection right here so this is
just the arrest net architecture that we
use
um instead of our backbone right
um so after we have gone through our
backbone
um we split our model architecture into
these two parts
so first of all we have this policy head
here above and at the beginning here we
just have a singular conf block and this
conf block will take the output from our
backbone as input like this
and then after we have gone through that
conflog we will then flatten out the
results here
and then we just have this linear layer
or fully connected layer between the
outputs for account block and then also
these neurons right here and at the end
we just want to have uh yeah nine
neurons in the case of tic-tac-toe
because we want to have one neuron for
each potential action right and then
tic-tac-toe there are nine possible
actions
so yeah at the end we will just have
these nine neurons right here and and
normally we would just get these logids
so just these standard outputs but when
we want to get this readable
distribution telling us where to play we
also have to apply this soft Max
function and this will basically turn
the outputs from our nine neurons to
this distribution of probabilities and
yeah then each probability we're
basically indicate us
how promising a certain action is right
okay so yeah this is why we have these
nine neurons here and then where we also
in practice later called the softmax
method right
so the second head this this value head
right here and here we also have the
singular conf block that is different uh
from this one right here so we have this
connection here as well and this also
takes the output from our backbone as
input and then again we would like to
flatten the output of this conf block
here out and we want to have this linear
layer of fully connected layer and
finally we just want to have one neuron
right here because remember this that
this value head should tell us how good
this state right here is and it should
just give a float
in the range of negative 1 to positive
one is output
and because of that we only need none
one neuron right and the best way to get
this range of negative 4 into positive
one is by also applying this 10h
activation function
onto this last singular neuron right
here so here's just a visualization of
the 10h function and basically this will
just squish all of our potential values
into this range of negative one to
positive one and yeah this is exactly
what we want for our value head
so ultimately we have
this model right here that takes this
encoded status input and on one hand it
will output the policy so just yeah this
distribution telling us where to play
and on the other hand uh it will give us
this value so just this estimation
telling us how good this state is right
here okay
so now we can actually build this inside
of our jupyter notebook
and here the first thing is that we want
to import pytorch
because we want to use the Deep learning
framework pytorch so first of all I will
also print the NP dot version so we
always get that right here and then we
will import torch like this let's also
print torch
dot version right here
okay so let's just do that okay so this
is my current torch version and I think
for yeah the loss we will use later on
we will have this multi-target cross
entropy loss and this has been added as
a feature just recently to pytorch so I
would just recommend to get this version
right here but or any newer version
um so if you have any problems you can
just use this one and I also have Cuda
support right here because of my Nvidia
GPU but you could also just get the CPU
Standalone pytouch version
depending on your setup right okay so
now additionally to torch we also want
to import torch
dot n n
s and n right here and then we want to
import
torch.nn.funk channel
like this s this big F right capital f
okay so now we can import these things
right here and then I will just create
this model and I will just create this
new cell above our MCTS implementation
so I will just call this class res net
then we have an N dot module
and inherit from that
so here we have our init
and first of all we have a game then we
have a num of rest blocks so this will
just be the length of our backbone right
instead of our architecture
and then we also have num hidden yes so
this will be the hidden size for our
conflict blocks right
Okay so
inside first of all we have to call it
super dot init
and now we can Define the start block
and this should be equal to an N dot
sequential
and first of all we just have this conf
block at the beginning so nn.conf
2D
and the input your hidden size is just
three because remember that we have
these three planes at the beginning and
then the output uh dim should be num
hidden
then for the kernel size we can just set
that to three and also we can set
heading to one right because when we
have kind of sizes 3 and padding as one
this conf block won't actually change
the shape of our game State directly so
it always be where the number of rows
times number of columns for these images
essentially right for these pixelves if
you want to look at this look at it like
an image
so after our conf 2D we also want to
have this batch Norm so NN dot patch
Norm
2D
then here we have just num hidden as our
hidden size
yeah in this page number will just
increase the speed speed for us to train
um essentially so now we can also have
this num and Android value
and yeah this radio will just turn all
the negative yeah they use two zeros so
clip them off basically and this way
it's also faster to train
and save up okay so this is just our
start block right here so first of all
just this confer to D then this batch
number to D and then our value
and now we can also have the
save.backbone like this this should be
equal to NN dot module list
and then here we just want to have this
array
and basically we want to have this array
of different rest blocks right inside of
our backbone
uh remember from this image right here
and
in order to do that we also have to
create this rest block class so let's
write class rest block
like this of NN dot module
and then first of all we have our init
again
and then we just have num hidden s input
here
and again we have to
inert our super class as well
um like this
[Music]
okay so now for each rest block we also
want to have our first conf block so
save dot conf1 this should just be equal
to
nn.conf 2D of num hidden for the input
hidden dim then num hidden for the
output in the
and then Kernel's size should be three
and then padding should be one here
so this is our first curve block then we
also have our first batch Norm block so
bn1 this should be equal to NN dot batch
Norm 2D
of num hidden as we hidden then we kind
of our second conf block so save to
conf2 should be set to nn.conf 2D
and like this and then again we have num
hidden here and I'm heading here
within a kernel size of
three
[Music]
and a padding of one
and now we can also Define the second
batch from success.bn2 set that equal to
nn.batch Norm today off num hidden as
well
so then let's also Define this forward
method so let's write Dev forward the
first one we have safe and then here the
X so the input
and then remember that we instead of our
rest block want to have this residual so
that we can later have this skipped
connection so let's create this residual
and set that equal to X
and then now we want to update this x
right here separately
and we can do this by first of all
calling self.conf one of X then calling
self.bn1 on top of that
and then also we want to have a radio
here so just F Dot
sorry capital f f dot value like this
[Music]
and so this is our X at this position
and then we also want to feed through
our second conf block here
so let's update X by calling save.pn2
of self.conf to
of X right here
so this way we have yeah went through
these two call blocks right here
and then now we can just sum up
um
this output with the residual right so X
plus equals residual right here
and then
now we can just again call the value
here so X should be
f
dot value of x
and now we can just return that X right
here so this way we have this nice
residual connection here and at the end
we just return the sum right
okay so now we actually can
create this backbone right here so in
order to do that we want to create a
rest block of num hidden
just for I in range
of num res logs
like this so this way we also have our
backbone right
so this is great and next
we can create this policy head so safe.
policy head like this this should again
be equal to nn.sequential
and instead of the sequential first of
all we want to have just this conf block
so nn.conf 2D
and here we have a num hidden as our
input hidden size then we have just 32
as our output in size
and then we can also Define a kernel
size and set that to three and have a
padding of one
and then again we want to call it batch
Norm here
and just this Ray U here
[Music]
okay
so
after we have went through this conf
block remember that we want to flatten
our results so let's just call it NN dot
flatten
here
and now we want to have this linear
layer right
so nn.linear and for the input we want
to have these 32 planes
multiplied with the number of rows and
multiplies with the number of columns so
time scale dot row count times game dot
column count right because remember that
we have a kernel size of 3 and a padding
of one for all of our conf blocks and
because of that we won't change the
actual shape of our state right
so because of that we can just when we
can want to get the input size of our
flattened output here and we can just
multiply the number of hidden planes so
32 with the row count with the column
count as well then for the output of our
linear layer we just want to have game
dot action size right
okay
um yeah so that's great and now we can
also Define a value head it's safe to
the value head like this and this should
be set to nn
Dot sequentia
and here first of all we also have
nn.conf 2D and for the input hidden them
we have just now hidden and for the
outputting we have just three and for
the kernel size we can set that to three
and heading to one again
and now we can also have a batch Norm
here
so patch node to D
and have three as the hidden size
and then again call it just already on
top of it
[Music]
and flatten our results here
okay so now we also want to have this
linear layer at the end
[Music]
and again for the input we have just
three times
game dot row count timescame dot column
count
and then for the output we just want to
have one right because we just want to
have one neuron here and then also
um we want to have this 10h activation
function right so we can just add an N
dot 10h right here
so now
um we have here this party finish and
next we can write this forward method
and for our resnet class so it's right
there forward
and take the
input X here
and then first of all we want to send
this x through our start block so X
should be safe dot start
block of X right and then we want to
Loop over
all of our rest blocks right here
instead of our backbone so let's write
four rest Block in safe Dot
um backbone
like this
um then here we can just set x to the
rest block of X right
so that's great
and now we have these X values right
here and next we yeah I can just get
this policy and this value here back so
first of all you can write policy
and here we can just set that equal to
save dot policy head
of x
then this value should be searched where
you head of x
and now we can just return our policy
and our value right here
[Music]
okay so let's just run that for now
and now we also want to test that this
is working so I would just create this
new cell right here and here let's just
start by creating a game of tick tock so
so this should be equal to this
tic-tac-toe class right here and let's
get this state by calling tick toe dot
get initial State like this and then
let's just update that state by first of
all setting state to tick tock toe dot
get next
state of State let's just say that I
don't know we play at the position two
for the player negative one
I'll post one in this case and let's
also play at
um position seven
for the player negative one
okay
um
[Music]
so now we can just print the state for
now
and yeah we get this state right here
okay so next we should
um
remember that we also have to encode our
state when we give it to our model
so we also have to write this new method
right here so here we just write def get
encoded state of safe and then just off
the state right here
and remember that we want to have these
three planes right so we can get this by
writing n coded State equals
NP dot stick
and then here we want to Stack first of
all these eight voltage that are equal
to negative one with the state of all
empty Fields so that the fields that are
equal to zero with these state where all
four of the fields they are equal to
positive form like this so yeah this
should be our encoded State and here
these widgets be booleans but rather we
want to have floats so let's just set
the type here for NP dot float 32.
and now we can just return this encoded
state
okay
um so let's test this out by writing
encoded State and you're setting that
equal to
Tick Tock toe but get encoded state of
this state right here let's just print
that here
okay so yeah now we see that we have
this uh just stayed right here and this
is our encoded state right so first of
all we have this plane for all of the
fields in which planet nectophone is
played so just this field right here
which is encoded as a one here
and then we have these empty Fields
right here and then we also have these
fields where play a positive one played
so just the sphere right here right
okay and so this is great and now we
want to get this policy and this value
right
so first of all we have to turn this
state to a tensor now that's so because
of that we can write tensor State and
set that equal to
rch dot tensor of encoded State like
this
then when we give a tensor to our model
as input we also always need this batch
Dimension right
um but here we just have one state and
not a whole batch of States so because
of that we have to unsqueeze
[Music]
if the Zero's axis
so what this does is that we that it
will essentially just create
further brackets around this encoded
state right here and this way we can
pass it
um through our model right
okay so now we have this tensor state
right here then we can get this policy
and this value by calling our model
that's why I need to Define our model so
that's right model equates res
net and for the game we have Tick Tock
too for the number of rest blocks we can
just set that to four and for the num
hidden we can set that to 64. okay so
now we can write policy value equals
model of this tensor state right here
and then we want to yeah process the
policy of the value so let's first of
all get this float from our value by
calling value dot item right here
since this will just be a tensor on WE
rather like to have the float and we get
this by calling dot item with this
tensor here and then we can also change
the policy
so here we can just write policy which
equates torch.soft Max
of this policy right here and for the
access we have to choose one because we
don't want to apply this soft mix on our
batch access but rather than this axis
where we have these nine neurons right
so this x is one
and
now we first of all have to
squeeze this again
so that we remove the
patch axis essentially and then we can
detach that so we don't have a grad here
when we turn this to numpy now so then
let's also take this to CPU and let's
call this to numpy here like this okay
so now we have this policy and let's
just print out both of these things so
right after there you want to print out
the policy and see whether this works
okay so nice uh now first of all we get
this value of 0.3 for this state right
here
and then this is our policy distribution
telling us where to play so just this
number of probabilities now you know
what let's also make this a bit more
visual so let's import
matplot lib like this dot Pi plot
um right here
yep s Pat
and then here we can just
write plt.bar
first of all of the range from our Tic
Tac Toe dot action size and then these
policy values right here
let's just write pat.show
okay so yeah let's uh so this is
basically how our policy looks like so
for each action and we have this bar
right here
um yeah telling us how promising this
action is and then obviously our model
was just initiated randomly currently so
we can't expect too much here and so
nothing actually but um
when we later have this trained model we
can expect this nice distribution of
bars telling us where to play right okay
so now we also have this Modi model
built and next we can start with
incorporating our neural network into
this multi-colored research right
so before we do so I I'd still like to
apply a small change here so
um let's just set a seat for torch so
that we have reproducible results so
that you can make sure that you at least
bit something similar to what I've built
right here so let's write torch.manual
seat and let's just set the C to zero
like this
so perfect
and then we can update
this multicolor tree switch right here
so the first thing is that we now want
to give a model here's input so this
will later on just be our res net so
let's also declare safe. Model S model
foreign
we want to do
so basically after we have reached the
leaf node we want to predict a value and
a policy
um based on the state of our Leaf node
and then we want to use this policy
when we expand so that we can
incorporate the probability and solve
the policy into the UCB formula that
makes sense so that when we choose a
note during our selection phase we are
more likely to choose nodes with higher
privacy values because of these were the
ones that seemed more promising to our
model right so we want to choose these
more often and work down the tree inside
of these directions where our model
guides us
so this is the one uh thing we use our
model for and the next thing is um
that we want to use the value we get
from our model to back propagate once we
have reached the leaf node so actually
we can completely remove the simulation
part so we don't want to do any rollouts
with random actions but instead we just
use the value we get from our model so
let's call this right here so we can
write policy
and value equals self dot model
and here we want to pass in the state of
our node right but remember that we want
to encode it beforehand so that we have
this three planes based on the players
um we have in tic-tac-toe or just for
the interference right so uh you might
remember this from the last checkpoint
so first of all we can write safe.game
dot get encoded state
and here we just have no dot state
and now we want to turn this encoded
State into a tensor
uh instead of just a numpy array so that
we can give it as input to our model
directly so we can write torch.tensor
off safe.game.gate encoded state of
node.state
so now we have to unsqueeze at the zeros
axis
and
um so let's write unsqueeze of zero
right here and this is because we always
need an axis for our batch right and
currently we aren't patching any states
so we just create this empty batch
basically with just this one stack right
here
so this is why we unscreased here
and yeah then we get a policy and the
value as a result and now remember from
the model checkpoint that we want to
turn this policy
um which is just uh with which are just
logits currently so just nine uh floats
we want to turn this into a distribution
of likelihoods so first of all we can
write policy equates torch.soft Max
of policy and then we have to set access
to one because we want to apply the soft
Max not on the batch axis but rather on
the axis of our nine neurons right in
the case of tic-tac-toe so after we have
called the softmax we would like to
squeeze again
at the zeros and axis so that we remove
this batch axis now so actually we want
to read revert this statement right here
after we have feed forwarded our state
through our model
and next we can call CPU in case we
might lose Jeep use GPU later and then
we can use numpy right here and also we
should use The torch.nograd Decorator on
top of our search method
um so
because we don't want to use this policy
and value for training immediately
rather we just want to use it for
prediction
so we don't want to store the gradients
um yeah of this tensors right here so we
just use no grid as a decorator so this
way
um yeah it's faster to run our Monte
Carlo research
so great so now we have our policy and
we have turned it into a numpy array and
we have applied the softmax activation
function
but next we also want to mask out all of
the illegal States
all of the illegal moves I'm sorry
because uh when we expand we don't want
to expand inside of directions where a
player has already played for example
right so we have to mask out our policy
on these illegal positions so we get the
valid moves first of all by calling
self.game dot get valid moves
and then for the state we can just use
node.state so the state of our Leaf node
right here
and
um
then we want to multiply our policy with
these valid moves
[Music]
so now all the illegal moves will have a
policy equal to a zero which is great
but again we have to rescale our
policies so that we have percentages
and we do this by just dividing with its
own sum so that the sum of our policy
will turn to one
um and yeah this will give us this nice
distribution we want so let's actually
also change the value and we want to
just get the float uh
from our one neuron of our value head
so we get this by calling value equals
value dot item so in pie torch if you
call Dot item on a tensor that has only
one float you will just get the float as
result
so that's great so now we have our value
and we have our policy so then we want
to use this value for back propagation
and we want to use this policy for
expanding right so let's call
node.expand with the policy as input and
let's remove this simulation part
directly so that we will use this value
right here for back propagation later on
in case we have reached a leaf node here
and we expand right
so this is great and
now there's some smaller things we can
just remove so first of all we can just
completely delete the simulation method
here
and then there are some more things and
first of all when we call the expand
method we immediately expand in all
possible directions because we just have
this policy right here and
um it doesn't make sense anymore to only
expand in One Direction once you had
reached a leaf node but rather we expand
in all directions immediately
so
um this also means that we don't need
these expandable moves right here
anymore
um because yeah
we will check the expandable moves by
calling dot Reddit moves later on
so also
um we can change this is fully expanded
method here and now we can just check
whether the land of our children is
larger than zero because remember when
we expand once we expanded all the
directions so if we have one child we
have we know that there aren't any more
children we could have right
so yeah this should be enough here
so yeah now this is working but next we
have to update
um this node.expand method right here
so let's do that here so first of all we
take this policy yes input
and then we want to Loop over our policy
right so we can write for action
and then prop so just the probability uh
at a certain action in enumerate policy
and then we can check for each action
whether the probability at the given
action is larger than zero so let's
write this prop it's larger than zero
and we can remove these two segments
here
and if this is the case let us just
create this new child right here and
let's depart it to the children
but remember that we want to use this
probability here inside of our UCB
formula later on during selection so we
want to store this probability inside of
our node object and we do this by
creating this new prior input here so
let's just prior to set prior to Zero by
default and let's define price after
prior here as prior
so the prayer will just be the
probability
um
that was given here when we initiated
the child and it is equal to the policy
at the given action from the parents
perspective
when we expanded our parents
so
um yeah now we have defined this prior
right here but we also want to
um yeah use it here when we create a new
node so let's just give here prop as
input for the prior
uh at the end like this so great so now
we have all of this ready so
um next we have to update the UCB
formula
since Alpha zero uses a different USB
formula than just a standard
multi-colored research
so I just brought an image up right here
so actually we remove the math.log and
we just wrap the square root around the
visit count of our parent then also um
we just add a one to the visit count of
our child and yeah so so that's
basically it
and so
first of all we have to say that if we
call this UCB formula on a child that
has a visit count of zero then we can't
calculate a q value right so let's just
set the Q value to zero in that case as
well so let's say if child dot wizard
count
equals zero then Q value should equal
zero then edits
I'm sorry Q value should be equal to
this formula ratio
so because now we don't back propagate
immediately on a note that has just been
created during expanding so it is
actually possible now to call this USB
method on here on a chart that hasn't
been visited before
so yeah this way we change this part
right here and then also we want to
update this part here below so that's
right
like of this image here
so let's first of all remove this
math.log
from here and then
here we want to add a one the visit
count of our child
and then we also want to multiply
everything up with the prior of our
child right so that we also use the
policy when we um
yeah when we select
um downwards of the tree
so this should be working now
so let's see see if we got everything
ready so yeah I think that's it so let's
just run this right here so first of all
I will just update C to be equal to 2.
and then we can create a model right
here so let's write model equals resnet
and then for the number for the game we
can just use sticker tool
for the number of rest blocks let's just
say four and for the number of our
hidden planes we can just set that to
64. then you know what also evaluate our
model right here so
currently this model has just been
initiated randomly right so we can't
expect too much but let's try this out
so oh sorry uh we're still missing the
model that he has argument inside of
what yes so yeah if it's
[Music]
so nice so now we see that with our
updated MCTS
um we played right here and you know
what let's say
um we would like to play on one
so yeah the MCTS played here and let's
okay uh I don't know it's just on this
Edge right here and the MCT has played
here so negative one and has won the
game so now we have our updated
multi-colored research ready and next we
can actually start to build this main
Alpha zero algorithm so in order to do
that let us just create a iPhone 0 class
and I will Define that just below our
updated MCTS
sorry let's remove that here
and Define it
down below here
so let's write class Alpha zero
and for the image
we'd like to take the model
then also an optimizer so this will just
be a pie torch Optimizer like Adam we
will use for training
and then also a game and some additional
arguments yes input
and next we can Define all of these
things right here so let's write self
dot model
its model self dot optimizer
liquids optimizer
and then write safe.game equals game and
save dot arcs should equal access way
and at the end we can now also Define
multi-colored research object inside of
our fs0 class so let's write safe.cgs
should be equal to MCTS
and when we initiate it when we initiate
our multi-colored research we want to
pass in the game the args and the model
so let's just run it game arcs model
just like this
so yeah let's just be standard in it of
our fs0 class and then next we want to
define the method inside and from the
overview you might remember that we have
these two components which is the save
play part and then the training part
and outside we just have this Alpha zero
wrapper right here so let's create our
self-play method
this
and let's just pass that right now and
let's also create our Training Method
like this
and let's pass that here as well so next
we can have this learn method
and this will be the main method we will
call when we actually want to start this
cycle of continuous learning where we
run sort of play get data use this data
for training and then optimize our model
and then close if play again with the
model that is much smarter right so for
this cycle we want to first of all Loop
over all of the iterations we have so
let's say for iteration in safe.args of
num iterations
[Music]
and then for each iteration we want to
create this memory class so just the
training data essentially for one cycle
so let's write our memory list here
let's uh so let's define memory right
here
and then we want to Loop over all of our
self-play games
so let's write four set play iteration
in safe.args of
save or in range sorry we need to
refinement shift
[Music]
um so in range of safe.args
of num
save play iterations
like this
and then for each iteration we would
like to extend the data we just got out
of our self-play method and we want to
extend this to this memory list right
here so let's write memory plus equals
save dot save play
um just like this so let me extend the
new memory and actually we'd like to
change the mode of our model so that we
so that the model is now an evalu mode
so that we don't have these batch knobs
for example during safe place
[Music]
and now we want to move on to the
training part so first of all we can
write safe.od.train like this
[Music]
and then we can save for Epoch in range
of safe.args
num epochs
and yeah for each epochs we like to call
this train method right here and we like
to give the memory as input so let's
write safe.train of memory like this
so let's also add memory here as an
argument
so that's great and at the end of an
iteration we like to store the weights
of our model right so let's write
torch.save of
safe.static
like this and for the path we can just
write model
and then the iteration
[Music]
with instead of an F string and write
dot PT
for the file ending
so let's also save the static of our
Optimizer so let's write torch.save off
safe.optimizer
dot State picked
then for the path again we can write
Optimizer and then iteration
[Music]
and take dot pts file ending here and we
have to turn our string into an F string
yeah so this is great and
um now that we have gotten our main Loop
ready
um we would like to focus on this
self-play method right here
so
inside uh we again have to define a new
memory so this will just be uh yeah the
memory inside of one own self-play game
and then we have to define a plane at
the beginning so let's say player should
equal 1 at the start and then we also
have to create an initial State and we
get the state by calling
save.game dot get initial State like
this
and then we
want to have this true Loop and inside
of this Loop we want to first of all
call the multi-colored research based on
the state we have then we want to get
yeah these action props as result
and next we like to sample an action
from this distribution of action
probabilities
and yeah so after we have sent it an
action we want to use this action to
play essentially so we will get a new
state
um yeah by calling self.game dot get
next State uh based on the Old State and
then once we have this new state we want
to check if this state is a terminal one
so if the game has ended and if indeed
the game is ended already then we want
to first of all return all of this data
to the memory here and here the data
should be structured in this Tuple form
where for each instance we have a given
State we have the action probabilities
of our MCTS and then we have the final
outcome right so whether the player who
played at the instance also was the
player that won the game at the end or
the player that lost the game or the
player that he didn't draw right so this
should be incorporated in the final
outcome
so so we can write y true like this
and here first of all we have to
remember that when we call mcts.search
we always like to be player one so we
first of all need to get this neutral
State and we can get this by recording
safe.game.change perspective so let's
write it right here
and for the state we just like to take
this state right here and for the player
we just want to take the player above
and yeah so that's great so now that we
have our neutral set we can get our
action props back from this MCTS search
right here
and we call it save.mcts.search
and we take this neutral State as input
so now that we have our neutral State
and our action props we can store this
information instead of our memory so
that we can later use this information
to get gather this training data so
first of all we can write self.memory
dot append
then we append the structure right here
of the neutral State and the action
props
and then also the player
so yeah now we want to sample an action
of the action props right and we can do
this by calling NP Dot random.choice
and for the number of different options
we can use the action size of our game
so in this case of tic-tac-toe that is
equal to nine so let's say
save.game.action size
and then for the probabilities we use
for sampling we just want to use these
actual props right here we got from our
MCTS
so like this
so now that we have sampled in action we
like to play based on this action rate
so we can say stage should equal safe
Dot
game dot get next
state
and we take give this Old State the
action and we play ideas input
and now that we have gotten our update
State we want to check if the state is
terminate or not so we write value this
terminal
equality save Dot Game dot get
value and terminated
[Music]
and we give the updated State and the
action we use to get this updated State
yes input
and then we can say if this terminate is
true so if it's terminal
and then we want to return this data
right so first of all we can write
return memory should be equal to this
new list right here
and then we want to Loop over all of
these instances inside of our memory or
sorry let's not write set of memory
about rather
memory just like this because we want to
use this mirror right here
so we can write four
hist
portrait state
Test action props
and then his player
in
memory
and for each instance we now want to get
the final outcome right at the given
instance because we need to store that
inside of our training data so we can
say this
outcome
and this outcome should be equal to this
value right here if his player is also
equal to the player
um we were when we achieved this value
right so if we were player positive one
when we played here and have indeed won
the game
and then we will receive a value as
positive one as well and we want to set
the his outcome for all instances in
which player positive one played to
positive one and we want to set the his
outcome to all instances in which player
negative one played to negative one
right so this outcome should be equal to
value
if
his player is equal to player
event edits we just want to receive the
negative value right
um and now we can
um depend this information to our return
memory
so let's write return
memory dot append
and yeah again we need
to append a tuple so I have brackets
inside of these brackets right here
and we want to attend the neutral state
but remember that we like to encode the
state when we give it as input to the
model so we can already encode it right
here so let's write
save.game dot get encoded state of this
neutral state
[Music]
for the state and then just the action
props from our MCTS distribution
and then just the hist outcome we cut
here
[Music]
so just like this
and sorry we went to append this to our
original memory read but not to return
immediately but after we have looked
through all of this we now can actually
return this written memory
just like this and all in all other
cases if we haven't reached the
Terminator note yet then we want to flip
this player around so that we are a
player negative one now uh if we were
player positive one previously so let's
write play
articles.game dot get component of
player like this
[Music]
so there's still some minor things I
would like to update right here so first
of all let's make this code more General
by changing negative value right here to
the value as perceived by the opponent
depending on the game we have uh inside
of our iPhone 0 implementation so that
we could also
um yeah run this in games where we have
only one player right so let's write
save Dot game dot gets opponent value of
the you like this so let's just more
General if we um
quote this method right here
so get opponent value
and the next thing would be that we want
to visualize these Loops right here and
the way we can do this is by having
these progress paths and we can get them
by using the tqdm package
so let's write import TQ
DM dot notebook
and you know what from tqdm.notbook we
want to import a t range like this
so then we can just replace these range
chords below
with a t range so
just a small difference right here and
now we want to check that this iPhone 0
implementation is working as we have
built it so far
so um
we want to create an instance of alpha 0
and um we like to do that we need a
model an Optimizer again and some
arguments
so we get the model first of all by
building a resnet but initially let's
just create an instance of tic tac toe
let's write tic-tac-toe liquids click
attack toe like this
and then we can write model that equals
rest net
and for the game we want to use the
stick-tac-toe instance which is created
and for the number of rest blocks we can
just say 4 and for the hidden dim we can
just say 64.
and now we want to Define an Optimizer
right so let's use the atom Optimizer as
an built-in pie torch so let's write
Optimizer equates torch.optum dot Adam
and then for the parameters we want to
use the parameters of our models such as
model.parameters
[Music]
and for the learning rate we can just
use
0.001 just a standard language for now
and
um
next we also need to refine these
arguments right here
and we can
do this by creating just another
dictionary
and for the exploration constant we can
just choose two again where the number
of searches we can choose 60
and then for the number of iterations on
the highest level we can just choose
three for now
and then for the number of self-play
iterations
um so the number of safe play games we
play for each iteration
um
durations we can set that to 500 for now
and the number of epochs can just be
equal to four correctly
you know what let's also lower this
amount to 10 for now so that we can see
that we can save our models
and let's just run that right here
oh sorry and now we want to create this
instance of alpha zero
and this should be equal to the cipher0
class
and the input should now be this model
we've created the optimizer we have
created and the game and args we have
created so it's right model
optimizer and for the game we can write
tic-tac-toe
and for the arguments we can use the
arcs here then we can run Alpha 0.11
like this
let's see if this works so nice so now
we get this a good looking bar we can
see that we are running these safe
player games
great so now we can actually implement
the Training Method inside of our Alpha
0 implementation so let's just change
this method right here and the first
thing we always want to do when we call
this method is that we want to shuffle
our training data so that we don't get
the same batches all the time
so we can do this by calling
randle.shuffle here of the memory
and if we want to use the use this we
have to import random here above
just like this
and nice so
now we can actually continue
um with this implementation right here
so next we want to Loop over all of our
memory and we want to Loop over it in
the batches right so that we basically
have a batch index and for each batch
index we can then sample a whole batch
of different samples
and then use these for training so the
way we do this is by writing for batch
index
then range and here we want to start at
zero we want to end at the length of our
memory
and then we want to step in the size of
safe.args.batch size
[Music]
and now we want to take a sample from
our memory right and we can get this
sampled by
uh calling the memory at the batch index
at the beginning
and we want to call it until batch index
Plus safe.args
dot batch size
but just remember that we don't want to
call it on any batch index that might be
higher than our Len of the memory
so we have to be careful here and we can
check that we don't exceed the line of
our memory by calling
Min of Len of memory
minus one
then the batch index plus self dot arcs
of batch size right here
so
this way we won't ever exceed this limit
correctly here
so now we want to get the states the
MCTS props and the final rewards from
our sample
and we can do this by writing State and
policy targets for the mcds
distributions
and value targets for the final reward
we get from Save play
and we get this from our sample by
calling the zip method
so the way
um this works is that we basically
transpose our sample So currently we
have just this list of tupils and each
Tupac contains a state a policy targets
and a value
but by applying this asterisk here and
then zipping it we actually get lists of
States lists of policy targets and list
of value targets so we transpose this
sample around basically
so now the state is a list full of MP
arrays the policy targets is a list full
of MP arrays and value targets is a list
of MP arrays but it's much more helpful
if we actually have all of these things
as NP arrays immediately
so let's change them by saying value and
policy targets and value targets and we
should be
equal to NP dot array
of State
and mp.array of policy targets
and NP dot array of value targets like
this
but remember for the value targets that
currently we only have this numpy Rand
inside we immediately have all of our
float values but it's much more helpful
if each of these value actually is in
its own sub array later on if we compare
to the output of our model so we can
change this by calling reshape here then
we say negative one for the batch axis
and then we just say one so that each
value will be in its own sub array
essentially
[Music]
so this is great and now we can turn all
of these three things into tensors so
first of all we can write state in which
liquid storage dot tensor of state and
for the D type we can just say
torch Dot float32
even though
um
yeah write this encoded State might be
and just adjust right now nothing float
so that's nice to change the detail here
and for the policy targets
we want to
also turn this into a tensor and change
the detail to flow 32.
um
forge.tensor like this of policy targets
here
yeah and then the D type should be equal
to torch
dot float
32 like this
and then we have our value targets
[Music]
and here we also want to turn this into
a tensor
and have value targets as the old input
and the D type again should be equal to
torch.float32
so great
um so now we have all of our tensors
ready and the next step is to get the
out policy and the out value
from our model by letting it predict the
state we have here
so let's write out policy
out value equals self dot model
of
the state right here
[Music]
and then now we want to have a loss for
the policy and a loss for the value and
we can first of all Define the policy
loss
and you might remember that this is a
multi-target cross-entropy loss so here
we can write F dot cross
entropy like this
and then first of all we have our out
policy and then we have our policy
targets
and yeah
so next we have our value loss
and here we use the mean squared error
so we can write value
[Music]
loss equals f
dot MSE plus like this and then first of
all we have our out value then we have
our value
targets
and now we want to take the sum of both
of these losses
to finally get just one loss so we can
write loss equals policy loss
plus value loss right here
so now we want to minimize this loss by
back propagating
so first of all we can write
optimizer.0 grid
[Music]
then we want to call last stop equals
and then we want to call it Optimizer
dot step so this way pytorch does all
the big propagation for us
and actually optimizes this model right
here
so this way we now have a better model
and then we can use this during
self-play so let's test this out
so here I will just uh quite this again
you know what let's actually set number
iterations to 500 now and I will now
test this for the number of iterations
that we have here
and then afterwards we can finally see
how this model has learned and yeah feel
free to train this way but you don't
have to and we will make it more
efficient later on so we can also just
test it here on my machine
okay sorry so I forgot to define a batch
size right here so let us just pick 64
as our default batch size and then we
can run this cell right here and we get
these nice progress bars during training
and I have just trained uh yeah the cell
right here and it took roughly 50
minutes just using the CPU of my machine
so now we actually have trained for a
total number of three iterations and
remember that we save our model at each
iteration because of this expression
right here so now let us actually check
what the neural network we have trained
understands of the game and we can do
this by moving up to this cell right
here so this is just where we tested our
randomly initiated model
so here when we Define our model let us
actually load the static
so let's write model to upload static
inside we can write torch.load
and for the path we can write model and
then two since we want to check the last
iteration and then PT for the file
ending and you know what let's also put
our model in the valley mode so let's
just run this right here
and then for this state right here we
get this distribution of where to play
so our model tells us that either we
should play in the middle right here is
player positive one or we should play on
this field right here and the corner is
player positive one
and you know what uh let's also test it
for this state right here
so
um two and fours player negative form
and then
[Music]
play a positive one
we have played on the fields of eight of
six
[Music]
so first of all now you can see that we
have copied the spot state from the
image right here
and yeah then we also encode it and then
we get this distribution of where to
play so now the neural network correctly
tells us that we should play on position
7 because we would win here
and yeah for the value we get a result
that is close to positive one because we
would just win if we play here so we
have a high estimation of this position
right here as a player positive one
so yeah and this is even better than the
distribution we have right here so
remember this is just what this scenario
network is a mathematical function put
out and we never did a Monte Carlo
research or anything when we got this
result here so we can perfectly see that
this mathematical function so this
neural network actually internalized the
multi-colored research by playing with
itself and now we can just call this
neural network with a given State and we
get this neat distribution of where to
play and also this nice float here
telling us whether the given state is a
good one or not for us as a player
great so now we can apply some tweaks to
our Alpha zero algorithm and the first
week we want to yeah add right here is
that we want to also be able to use GPU
as a device
since that might be way faster for
training depending on your setup
so we can add GPU support by declaring a
device right here
and for the device we can say that it
should equal to torch.device
and the device should be Cuda so yeah
Nvidia GPU if torch.cuda dot is
available
[Music]
and then edits we can just set it to CPU
like it was initially
and yeah we want to
then use this device and give it to our
model as an argument
[Music]
so this also means that we have to
edit right here to our resnet class
so let's set device right here
and then we will first of all
add it as a variable here so self.device
should equal device
and then we also want to set our model
to the device it was given so let's
write save.2 device right here so that
we turn our model to GPU for example if
we have Cuda support on our machine
yeah so that's the first part and now we
also want to use this device first of
all during set play and then second of
all during training right so let's move
to the safe play part right here
and
we use our model during self-play when
we get these action props right here
during our MCTS search because yeah we
call our model right here
so yeah when we get this policy and this
value right here and yeah we also want
to
turn this tensor into a tensor that is
on our device we have declared so we can
do this by writing device should equal
self dot model
dot device
like this
and now we also want to use GPU for uh
or we want to add GPU support during
training
so let's move to the training part right
here and we can first of all
yeah move this data to our device since
we use it here's input to our model
let's write device equals
search.model.device
and then we also use these policy
targets and value targets and we compare
them to the outputs of our model so we
also have to yeah move them to the
device of our model so let's write
self.device let's write devices with
self dot model dot device again right
here
and also right here down below
okay so yeah now we should have GPU
support as well so that was fast
and now there are several more tweaks
so if uh yeah the next week we can apply
right here is that we also want to add
weight decay since
um we have this A2 regularization in our
loss
um for f for zero um like you can see on
this image right here so we want to
write weight decay
and we can just set that to
0.001 like this so this would be fine
and yeah so now we have way Decay and
GPU support added to Alpha zero and next
we also want to add a so-called
temperature
so remember when we
sample an action from these action props
right right here currently we just use
the visit count distribution of the
children of our root node as the
probabilities and then we take these
probabilities for sampling right
but actually we want to be more flexible
because sometimes we would rather like
to explore more and so also uh you know
sometimes take a visit count uh take
children or actions more often that
haven't been visited that often
and
um sometimes we also want to exploit
more so so we want to tend to always
just pick the actions that look the most
promising to us
so the way we add this flexibility is
that we
get some temperature action props so we
basically tweak this distribution right
here and then we will use the Tweet
distribution as the probabilities when
we sample an action
so let's write temperature action props
like this
and we get these by
first of all
using the old action props
then we want to power them
by 9 divided by self dot arcs dot
temperature
select this
and now we also have to Define
temperature in our arcs right here
let's write temperature
and set that to 1.25 in this case so now
we have declared this temperature right
here and actually what this does uh in
the case for a temperature that is
larger than one you can see that
you have the
number we use for the power actually
gets much smaller and what this then
does as a result is that we squish all
of our
probabilities much closer together so
that we actually do more of exploration
because
we higher our temperature actually gets
to Infinity the more it would be as if
we would just take completely random uh
actions sampled from just this random
distribution
and on the other hand if our temperature
would move down we can see that this
number would actually move up
so if our temperature would turn to zero
for example or close to zero and not
zero directly then it would be as if we
would take
just the arc Max of our distribution
right here so we want to do exploitation
and not exploration right so this
temperature right here basically gives
us the flexibility to decide whether we
want to rather take a more random
actions that do exploration or whether
we just want to
exploit and take the actions that look
most promising at the current time
so yeah this is great and now we also
have uh yeah our final tweak we want to
add to Alpha zero and that is that we
also want to apply Some Noise to the
policy that was given for our root node
at the beginning of a Monte Carlo
research
so when we
um
when we give our root note a policy we
basically want to add some noise so that
we also explore more and move in some
directions that maybe we haven't checked
before so that we also make sure that we
don't miss on any possible promising
actions
so the way we add this noise
to our root note is that we first of all
have to
um yeah add these statements uh to the
top right here as well so that we
um also add the policy
at the beginning and basically separate
the from the steps right here
so first of all
we should
get a policy and the value
by calling save.moded
and then here inside we have
torch.tensor
then we have safe.game dot get
encoded State sorry
[Music]
and then for the state we can just take
the state
um for root but this is equal to this
state right here so let's just save this
one
and for the device again we want to use
the device of our model so that we could
use GPU
[Music]
um
so self dot model.device right here
and then again we have to unsqueeze at
the end so that we have a axis for our
batch
[Music]
so this great
um so now we get this policy at this
value and actually let's just turn this
value into a blank variable because we
don't need it at the top so this should
be more readable now
and now we want to again tweak our
policies we have a tab right here
so let's first of all use soft Max right
here
so policy should be great to torch.soft
Max
of policy
for the access we want to use the first
axis
and so that we don't use the soft mix on
the batch axis
then again we have to squeeze at the end
uh turn our tensor to a CPU
and then just get the numpy array out of
it
so now again we want to get some valid
moves and then multiply our policy with
them
so that we mask out the illegal moves so
the lid moves should equal to save.game
dot get valid moves
off state right here
and then policy should be multiplied
with these
[Music]
and then again we can now add some noise
right here so after that we would just
again turn our policy to this
distribution of probability so we want
to divide it with its own sum
[Music]
so now here we actually want to add this
noise to our policy so that we yeah do
some more exploration during a
multi-colored research
so the way we can add this noise is
shown here on this image
so first of all this should be the
updated policy for our root node
and then we get this updated policy by
first of all multiplying our old policy
with this coefficient right here and
this coefficient is just a number
smaller than one so basically
we lower all of our policy values uh in
selfie distribution and then we add
um
the basically opposite coefficient so
also number smaller than one
um
multiply it with this noise right here
and yeah this should just be our updated
policy
so this Epsilon value here is just
floats smaller than one this n
value right here is a noise called
dirichlet random noise
and we get this by just using NP dot
random.urysled right here
and yeah basically for us this will just
give this a distribution of random
values and we basically will add them to
our policy multiplied with this
coefficient that is smaller than one
so this way we basically change our
policy a bit to also incorporate some
Randomness so that we then can explore
more rather than just always walking
down the tree and the way that our model
tells us because at the beginning our
model doesn't know that much about the
game so we also want to make sure that
we do some exploration as well
so let's add this right here so policy
should first of all be 1 minus self dot
arcs of
delish LED Epsilon
[Music]
like this and then multiplied with our
old policy
and then we want to add
the second part right here
so this should be safe.args of D Rich
Let's Epsilon again
[Music]
and then we want to multiply it with
NP Dot random.drichlet
and yeah inside here we just
[Music]
um
want to use this Alpha value so give
that as input to our MP3 random.tree
slat and this Alpha basically changes
the way our random distribution looks
like and is this based on the number of
different actions we have for games so
in the case of tic-tac-toe our Alpha is
quite high so roughly equal to
0.3 if you just want to use it because
that turns out to be looking well
but it might also change depending on
your environment
here then we want to
[Music]
use hash dot arcs
let
Alpha now let's actually move that to
the next line so it's more readable
and
then we want to multiply this array
with the action size of our game
[Music]
so
and actually we also have to move this
part here below so that we mask out our
moves after applying this random noise
or not before so
let's just copy them over
below
okay right so now we also added this
um
yeah noise to our policy and now we can
also use this policy we got right here
to expand our root node
so let's write root dot expand
and then
um yeah just use this policy right here
and now there's just a minor change we
can still add
and that is that currently when we
expand our root node at the beginning
[Music]
um
we won't back propagate immediately so
that means that our root node will have
children but the visit count of our root
node will still be equal to zero so that
we means that when we select right here
we will call this UCB formula with the
visit count of our parent being zero
and if this wizard count of our parrot
is zero then
basically this means
that
all of this will basically move away
because we just turned to zero as well
so
um this also means that we don't use our
prior when we select a children for the
child for the first time
so actually in order to make this better
we should just set the visit count of
our root node to 1 at the beginning
so you know what let's write visit
cones
let's set that one right here and
this also means that we have to get
visit card right here and the default it
should just be zero but
yeah for the root note it should be one
at the beginning so that we um
immediately uh use the information of
our prior when we select the child at
the beginning of our Monte Carlo
research
okay great so now we can run all of
these
sets again
and then see if this is working so we
also have to add a direct light Epsilon
here
[Music]
and yeah this should just be equal to
0.25
and then the result
Alpha
and I just set that to 0.3 like I told
you
okay so now let's test it out
okay so we still have a CPU device
somewhere
and let's see where that could be
oh um I haven't run this right here this
is the arrow sorry so here we have to
also
add a device and for this right here you
know what let's just say torch dot
device of CPU
and then we can run this again
okay so perfect now that's running and
yeah for
this current Setter with tic-tac-toe it
shouldn't be that much faster but later
on when we use more complex games GPU
support will be much nicer
and also this
these other tweaks should help to make
our model more flexible and actually
yeah make it easier to always get to a
perfect model at the end
so nice so I will just train this again
feel free to also train it but you don't
have to I can I've also uploaded all of
the weights and you can find them on the
link below in the video description
so let's just train that and then we can
briefly check it again and then we will
also expand our agent so that we can
also play the games of uh Connect Four
as well to tic-tac-toe
so see you soon
okay great so now I've trained
everything right here and now we also
want to check that our model has learned
how to play the game of tic-tac-toe so
in order to do that right here we have
to move up to this again and then you
know what you know what let's also
Define a device right here so let's
write device equates torch.device of
Cuda
if torch.cuda dot is available right
here
then else we can just use CPU for our
device
and then first of all we want to use
this device right here when we Define
our model
and then we also want to use this device
for the tensor state that is a stack
we'll use
for the monitor predict the policy and
the value so let's write device
right here as well and then we also have
to the USB device when we
load the static
from this file right here and that is
when we have a map location
that's right that location equates
device here as well
so let's now let's just run this again
and we see that we get this nice
distribution and this nice value again
so we can also see that our model has
learned and by the way um here we aren't
even masking out our policy
so the model has learned itself that you
know these moves aren't that great right
here because so you can't even play here
because someone else has played without
us even yeah
masking these illegal moves out so
that's nice and now we can move on to
also train our model or iPhone 0 on the
game of Connect Four great
so let's also define a class for the
game of Connect 4 but before we do that
let's also add this representation
method to our tic-tac-toe game
so let's write Dev wrapper like this
save and then here we can just return
the string of tic-tac-toe
and this string is yeah also the result
we would get when we call this object
here instead of a string representation
so this means that we can use this
information down below
when we save our model
for each iteration during learning so we
can just add
game right here
so basically we'll also add the name of
our game to this model and this
Optimizer weight or Statics when we save
them so that we won't override
our models when we train for the game of
Connect Four
um yeah
so that's great and yeah now that we
have done this part let us actually just
copy this
game over right here
[Music]
so that's great and now let's use it to
define the game of Connect Four
and for the game of Connect 4 first of
all we have a
row count that is equal to six we have a
column count that is equal to seven
and then the action size is just equal
to the column code
[Music]
and then also let's add a variable for
the number of stones you need in a row
to win in the game so let's write save
dot in a row and let's set that equal to
four
and for the representation we can change
the string to connect four here
and yeah the initial State can stay the
same because we just want to get this
here blank array with row count being
the number of rows and column count
being the number of columns so that's
great and now we have to change this get
next State method right here
because this action will just be a
column uh so we're telling us where to
play it and the first step now is that
we have to check get a row back
um
and
we get this row by looking at the given
column then we want to look at all of
the fields inside of this column that
are equal to zero so the that are empty
currently then we want to basically take
the deepest empty field inside of this
column because yeah this is where we
would play and connect for and yeah this
uh would just then be the row we use for
playing
so we get this by calling np.max
since yeah in a number array um you
start at zero at the top end then move
your values get higher if you move down
basically on the rows so we take np.max
of np.where off this state at the given
column
yeah and the state here should
equal it to zero right so yeah MP dot
where will just again give us V indices
of all of the empty fields and then
empty.mp.max will have give us the
highest in ECU because yeah this is
where we would play and Connect Four
because yeah the stone will just fall
down until
um yeah this is uh already non-empty
field
so now we have a row and technically we
also have a column because of this
action right here so we can now write
state of
row of column
and set that equal to this player right
here we have given here's input
and yeah so now that's great and next we
want to move over to this method right
here so we have this this get valid
moves right here and for the git valid
moves we just want to check the
um yeah row just at the top
and then we want to see whether the
fields at this row are equal to zero or
not and these are all available moves so
we can just write state
of a zero so at the basically upmost row
yeah and then this should be equal to
one
um
if it is valid and yeah otherwise we
just have an illegal move on this given
action
okay and now we want to check for the
win and frankly I'm just going to copy
this method over right here so
basically where we do the same checking
asymptote we are where first of all
we check for the vertical
there are possibility of a win and then
for a horizontal one and for these two
diagonals based on this action right
here that was given as input it's just
that compared to tick-tac-toe it's a bit
more complex where we actually have to
uh walk in both directions and then keep
checking whether we
have stones in these directions that are
equal to our own Player sign also have
this get value and terminated method and
this can just stay the same for both
games good opponent can stay the same
get opponent value can stay the same
change perspective also stays the same
and get encoded State yes also the same
rate here and I just noticed a small
mistake and that is when we use get next
step right here we can't reference
column because here we have defined our
columns action here from the top so
let's just replace column with action
like this
and now we can check
um that this
is actually working in practice as well
so we can do this by making our code
more General and here we just replace
tic-tac-toe with game
then we use game inside here
and we use game inside here as well
use game like this
again here
um and that's okay right here
so let's remove this instance of take
your toe
and yeah this one it's wet
and yeah so that should be fine
now the should be no more instances of
Tic-tac-toe and next let's replace this
game take that Toe with the game of
Connect Four
let's set the number of searches to just
20 so we can validate
let's say 100 here
and then let's change the size of our
model to be equal to
9 for the number of rest blocks and 128
for the hidden dim so that we have a
larger model than we let the trend
Connect Four
and now we can check whether this is
working or not
so first of all we also miss the
argument of device
so let's add that right here as well so
that's right torch Dot
device
of Cuda
if
torch.huda dot is
available
like this and then it's we can just use
a CPU
and yeah now we want to use this device
instead of our model class
so let's use it right here
and yeah so that should be fine
so let's run this again
okay perfect so now we have this game of
Connect Four let's say that we want to
play at the position of
four or five sorry
and you will still have a problem
so delete Epsilon is also not set right
here so let's copy these values over
um like this
but let's add teams like Epsilon to zero
so that we don't use noise here
um okay so I've played here the model
has played here you know what let's play
as one
that the model has played zero again
let's play a two
[Music]
see well multiplied play that zero again
and then we can just play at three like
this and we have one
so at least we check that the game of
Connect Four is working now but yeah
obviously our model is terrible because
we don't do that many searches right
here and also we haven't trained
anything yet so obviously our model is
garbage but let's change that now so
let's also train a model for the game of
Connect Four and then again test our
results here and we can do this by just
applying some minor changes right here
so first of all we should also make this
cell right here more generous so we
write game and then for the game we just
will use Connect 4 here
and then we also have to set the game to
just game instead of the resonate and
you know what because Connect 4 is
harder to train let's
change the number of rest blocks to 9
and let's change the num of our hidden
Dimensions to 128.
and then we also have to use game right
here during our Alpha zero initiation
and then we can also slightly tweak
these hyper parameters here so first of
all for the number of searches we want
to use 600 then for the number of
iterations we can use something like 8
maybe for now and then for the batch
size we can also increase that to 128
so yeah and next we can just run that
and this should take a lot longer
um but we will also increase the
efficiency of it later on so feel free
to just use the weights that I've
uploaded in the description down below
so you don't actually have to train this
all yourself since it might at least on
my machine correctly take a couple hours
so see you soon
okay now I've trained Alpha zero on the
game of Connect 4 using these arguments
right here and frankly I've just trained
it for one iteration since even that one
iteration took several hours to train
right so now we want to increase the
efficiency so yeah that will be way
faster for us to train also for these
rather complex environments
but yeah so still it was nice to train
for this one iteration because now we
can evaluate our model and find out
whether we had at least learn something
so let's move to this evaluation set
right here
and now when we create this model we
also want to load the state date from
the weights that we saved after we have
trained for this one iteration here
right
so here when we create our model in this
line right here we can write model dot
load State stick like this then inside
we can write torch.load and then we want
to reference this path right here
and so we can write model and for the
iteration we will just use zero since we
started zero and we have only trend for
one iteration and for the game we will
use Connect Four and for the file ending
PT again
and let's also Define a mapped location
and set that equal to device so this way
if your device would change during
training compared with the duration you
could still load the state deck like
this right here
so yeah this might be nice so let's run
the cell again and you know what let's
just play it six here so yeah now I'm
going to play it in the middle like this
so let's just play it six again
and yeah our model to defend this
position so let's just I don't know okay
let's see right here
and the model bit of this Tower right
here
let's play Let's see again
building up the tower let's just play
that zero again and our model finished
this Tower right here and first it has
won the game so we can still see that
our model isn't playing perfectly and
obviously I just played in the corners
to yeah check for some simple intuition
about the game on the modded side yeah
but we can still see that it is much
better compared to the initial model we
had where it only wanted to play instead
of this uh column right here right so
um that's great
um and now we also want to increase the
efficiency of our fs0 implementation
right
so actually now the main part is
completely done and you should have this
intuitive understanding of how the
algorithm works but like I said it would
be nicer to increase yeah the speed we
got when training and especially the
speed rings have played with it
so how can we do that and here we want
to basically parallelize as much of our
Alpha zero implementation as possible
because these neural networks are built
in a way where we could batch up our
states to then get here parallel
predictions for the policy and the value
especially when we run ourselves play
Loop
so one maybe way in which you could
parallelize this other implementation
here is by using a package like Ray that
would basically yeah create this threads
that are independent from each other and
then basically use that to yeah harness
all of your GPU power
but I'd rather like to build this
parallelized version in a more pythonic
way like this so just inside of our
Jupiter notebook again
so let's actually do that
um
so we will actually
basically
patch up
all of these different states then get
policy and value predictions and then
distribute them again to our safe play
games so that we play several safe play
games in parallel and this way we can
essentially drastically increase the
speed of our Alpha zero implementation
so the first thing we want to do here is
that we also want to add this argument
of non-paralleled games here to our
dictionary
come on
and for now I just set that to 100 so
the idea is that we want to play all of
these yeah self-play games in parallel
and then when we reference our model we
will batch up all of our states instead
of our MCTS search
and this way we can drastically reduce
the amount of times that we call our
model in the first place
and yeah thus on one hand we fully
utilize our GPU capacities and on the
other hand here we can just decrease the
amount of times we call our model and
thus also
um yeah have a higher speed right
so
the way we can yeah change
this or update our other implementation
is the first of all we want to just copy
this class here over
so I would just create this new class
here and I will call this iPhone 0
parallel
and then we also want to update the
Monte Carlo tree search so I will also
copy this class here over as well
and I will call this MCTS parallel like
this so
let's write it like this
so yeah now we have our parallel F0 and
mcds classes
and here we want to change the
implementation of the save play Method
and because of that also the
implementation of this search method
right here
so now that we have got this class
um
we also want to create a new class
and here we basically want to store the
some information of a given self-play
game
so that we yeah can Outsource some
information from our Loop when we Loop
over all of these given games
so let's create class and I will just
call this SPG for set play game and then
we can also have an inlet here
and for the unit we want to pass in a
game so click the tool for example or
Connect Four
and then first of all we want to have a
state here so initially this should just
be the initial state of our game right
so we can set save.day to game dot get
initial State like this
and then we also want to have a memory
inside here and this should just be an
empty list at the beginning
and yeah then we also want to store a
root and that should be none at the
beginning and we also want to store a
note here this should also be set to
none at the beginning
and yeah so this is everything we need
here for this class right here
and yeah so this way we can later store
some information here
okay so now we want to update this set
play Method right here
um
so first of all we want to call it less
often since every time we call this
method
um
we will call it 400
potential games that are played in
parallel right so here and when we Loop
over our numset play iterations
we want to divide that with the games we
play apparently
so save dot args of
sorry and I'm parallel
games like this and also when we
um yeah create this if play game class
right here I've just forgot to add those
brackets right here so we should just
add them yeah okay so yeah inside here
first of all
um we can remove this state right here
since we store our state and we save
click games right
and then also we can really name this
memory to the return memory since this
right here won't be the actual memory um
in which we store our
yes State and action props and Player
Two Bits initially but rather this will
be the state that we will return at the
end so
uh the list we currently have here right
which we won't need later on
okay so then the player can stay just
the same because even though we play
games in parallel we will always just
flip the player after we have looped
over all of our games right
so this way all of our games in parallel
will also always be at the same player
right because we always start at player
one and then we can just flip for other
games pyramid as well
Okay so
now we also want to store our self-play
games here
so I would just call this spgs like this
and maybe let's just sorry maybe like
say play games like this
and here we want to have a list of all
of our Circle games so one Circle game
should be created using this SPG class
we have defined below here and inside we
want to pass the safe.ame we have here
this our Alpha zero class
and we want to create the set play game
for
SPG in rangeof.args
and then nump parallel games right
so this way we create this list for all
of our safe play games
and yeah we will basically give them the
game in each case okay so now we have
these safely games right here and next
we want to change this file through
um you know expression here because this
way we would stop after one game has
finished but rather we want to keep
running our self-play method until we
all of ours have play games are finished
so we can check this by saying while the
land of SP games
is larger than zero so
we implemented this way that once a
software game is finished we will just
remove it from RSP games list because of
that we can just check here whether we
have any set play games inside of our
list right
so uh great um so the next step right
here would be to get all of these states
of our self-play games first of all
inside of our while loop
so let's get all of the states here
and we can get all of the states first
of all as a list
by saying
SPG dot state
for SPG in Sp games like this
[Music]
so yeah this way we just have a list of
all of our states that are installed
inside of our class
and now we can turn these states into
just a number array so the best way to
do this is just by calling np.stack here
of this list of numpy arrays and this
way we will basically get one large
number array right
okay so here we have all of our states
and next we also want to get the neutral
States
so first of all we can just change the
naming right here and then here when we
change the perspective we just have to
write States here instead of state and
now we will change the perspective for
all of our states basically in just yeah
one function call right so this is what
we can also increase the efficiency
since
um yeah changing the perspective works
the same way if we have several States
because we would just multiply our
values with negative one in case that we
have player set to negative one and yeah
here we we can just do the same right
so this is great and
now we can also pass these neutral
states to our Monte colored research
and we have basically finished this part
right here so let's now change
the Monte Carlo research search method
and yeah so first of all we want to now
give States yes input so these are the
neutral States we've just created
and now we can also
first of all I change the order so let's
just
paste this one here
below
and then we can work on the policy and
the value first
and so
move it like this Okay so
yeah first of all we get this policy on
this video and like I said we can also
do this with all of our batched States
so that's where we just get several
policies and values back here as a
return and that's great
but we still have to keep two things in
common so first of all we don't need to
call it unsqueeze here because now we
have a batch so we don't need to create
this fake batch access right
and then we also um have to update this
get encoded State method right here so
because the way it is currently
implemented
um
it's only working if we pass it one
state at a time
because this get encoded State method
which yeah create these three planes for
the fields in which play negative front
plate or these uh the fields that are
empty or the fields and which player
positive one is played right so it will
always first of all give us these three
planes then inside of these planes that
will give us the other fields right but
we want to change the order here because
now the first axis we basically want to
have here all of our different states
and then for each state we would like to
have these three planes right so we
don't want to have these three planes at
the beginning but after our batch access
basically right if that makes sense so
we have to basically swap the axis of
this encoded state right here so that it
would also work if we have several
States and not just one that we use when
we call this method here
so first of all we can check whether we
have several States or not and we can
check this by checking whether the Len
of state.shape
it's really quick to three right
because normally as the land of our of
just one set would be two right where we
have the rows and then the columns
and if we also have a batch axis then
the Len would be three because first of
all we have a batch then we have the row
something we have the columns
and yeah so if this is the case then we
want to create this new encoded state
[Music]
like this
um
and
it should basically be equal to NP dot
swap access
like this
and then here we want to pass in the old
encoded state
then we want to swap the axis 0 and 1
right so that we
don't so that the basically the new
shape should be the size of our batch
then three and then the number of rows
and then the number of columns right
instead of having three then the size of
our batch and then V number of rows and
number of columns right if that makes
sense so basically we swap these X's
right here
um so that's great and now we can also
copy this over to the game of
tic-tac-toe as well
and yeah oh sorry I just noticed that we
had NP dot swap access using an e
instead of it I so that's just my
mistake and let's update this for both
of our games
and yeah so this should be working now
okay so now we can keep updating
this CTS search method
so first of all
um
we now get these policies and these
values package return right at the
beginning we don't need our values so we
just get these policies and we can
rename the state here to States
and then when we
keep processing the policies it's nice
that we call the soft Max this way but
again we don't want to squeeze since we
want to keep our batch axis the way it
is currently
and then when we add the noise to this
policy we also have to make sure that
the shape of our noise is equal to the
shape of our policy so we can add a size
right here
and the size should just be equal to
policy.shape of zero right so this way
we basically create noise for each
different state so for each different
self-care game essentially
okay so this is great and
now we have this yeah process policy
here ready for us
and the next step would be to allocate
this policy to all of our self-play
games
so we first of all have to also add the
self-play games here to our MCTS search
as the argument
and let's also
add them here because of that
and now we can work with them so
here we basically want to Loop
um over all of our self-play games
so I will just write for I then SPG
in enumerate and then say play games
like this
and yeah inside of each separate game we
first of all want to get the valid moves
and we can get the valid moves from the
state
for the given Supply game right and we
get this state by looking at the states
at the position of I right here since
this is the index we get when we
enumerate through our self-play games
and this is also the same index as the
one we have when we basically stack all
of our states up together right so we
can just
uh yeah call it like this so um now
first of all we get our valid moves and
then we multiply the policy with it but
we don't want to multiply all of the
policy with it but rather just the
policy at our position right
so let's also find the policy for the
city to play games let's just write SPG
dot policy like this this should be also
equal to the policy at the position of I
so now we can multiply this SPG policy
with our valid moves
and then again we also want to divide
this SPG policy with its own sum
so that we at the end have this
distribution of percentages right okay
so now we create this root right here
and first of all we should also give
yeah these states at the position I here
for the state
and then also we have to make sure that
this route will be equal to SBG dot root
right because we want to store it inside
of this class right here
okay so now we have this SPG dot root
and we can also expand it so let's write
SPG dot root dot expand like this
and then we will expand it with the safe
play game policy
now we have here okay so that's why we
already have saved a lot of uh yeah
a lot of calling our model right because
we batch up all of our states here so
this is great and now we also want to
keep doing this inside of our actual
iterations right
so here when we basically have our num
searches we also want to Loop over our
circular games again
so let's again write for I then
SPG in enumerate SP games like this
and then we can continue with this part
right here
so for each set play game first of all
we want to get the note and we get this
note by calling spg.root right here and
then we can just continue with these
things right here
and yeah so now
um here we would call it our model again
right and we want to basically
yeah also parallelize this model call
right here
so the way we can do this is by turning
this if statement around so instead of
checking whether we haven't reached the
terminal node we want to check whether
we have reached infected terminal nodes
so this is terminal
and in this case we will back propagate
directly
so I would just copy this over right
here
and in all other cases
we want to store the node
that we have reached here inside of this
search instead of ispg class as well
right so edits we can just write
SPG dot node should equal this node
right here
and to make sure that we always start
with node being one so that we can later
differentiate between the self-play
games in which we have reached a
terminal node and then which all the
safe play games that are uh that we want
to expand on here later on we also have
to say that SPG
dot node should be equal to none like
this
so because of that we can just move that
out of
this Loop right here
and you know what I believe we also
don't need this enumerate Loop so let's
just remove it so
it's a bit easier to read it this way
Okay so
now we basically
have stored all of our expandable nodes
instead of our SPG classes so first of
all we now want to find out which safe
play games are expandable or not
so let's write expandable
spgs
oh that's right let's say games like
this
[Music]
um
and here we want to have the list and
then we want to store the mapping index
so basically the index we can later use
when we allocate this policy and this
value back to our list of software games
so we want to get the index basically
for each safe play game
um so for each SPG where our node is
expandable right here right so we can
just write mapping
index for mapping index
then in range of
Len
um SPG or save play games like this and
then we only want to get the index for
all of our safe play games where
um safe play game dot node is equal is
not equal to num right
since this will be the safety games that
are expandable
so if SP games
[Music]
of mapping index
dot note
then is not none like this
yeah this way we get the yeah indices
for all of our expandable safe play
games
and next we can check whether there are
even any expandable games so you can
just write if Len of expand to the SP
games
larger than zero and in this case we
again want to
yeah basically stack up all of our
states and
then also get these encoded States right
here so that we can then get this policy
at this value so first of all we can
write states that set that equal to NP
dot stack again
of
and here we can just write
SPG
dot note dot state
for SPG in
SP games like this
and then
oh sorry for
again we have to change this up a bit
sorry rather we have to write SP games
of
um
I I believe
or just mapping index like this
if we want to reference this one again
here
so self-play games of mapping
index.note.state
form mapping index
and then in
this expandable SP games right here
so in expandable
SP games
[Music]
like this okay so this way first of all
we get this list
of yeah the state for the nodes that are
expandable
um yeah basically for all of our
self-play games that we can expand right
here right
so okay now we have these states right
here and we also want to encode them but
we can just move over to this part again
so I will just copy this over right here
[Music]
so now again we get this policy and this
value back
and inside here first of all we can use
these expandable or these states right
here
and then we also don't have to unsqueeze
again because we already have a batch
then here we don't have to squeeze again
because we want to keep this batch as it
is
okay so yeah now we don't have to have
to add a noise right here so now we can
again Loop over
our
um expanded SP G's essentially right
so
we don't uh have to do this and stuff
because if statement that you could I
mean
not really changing much here so now we
want to first of all have the index
um that we can get our policy at the
given position and then we also want to
have this mapping index
so that we can then allocate this policy
at index I to the self-play game at
index mapping index if that makes sense
because the yeah index
um here when we enumerate is not aligned
with the index of our safe play games
right because we only look for over a
selected number of self-play games right
so for I if the mapping index has been
enumerate
then we want to again enumerate over our
expandable
let's Speed games like this
and then here we can just
um yeah basically get these valid moves
and this policy
and then we want to expand and back
propagate here
to move that magnet here
um so that's great and
now first of all we again want to get
the SPG policy and the SPG value so
let's get SPG policy by yeah getting the
policy at the position of I
of the SPG value should also be the
value at the position of I
so let's call this right here
okay so now we have our SPG policing of
on our SPG value so now we're going want
to get these valid moves and we get this
well it moves by first of all
getting the state of our node for the
given self-player game and here we want
to use this mapping Index right so here
we can just call it safe play games
at the position of mapping index
and then here we want to
get the node of this state right here
and what let's also just
um I think just throw this into a very
big I think this is nicer so just write
mode Eclipse
um
save play games of the position of
mapping index.note
and here we just want to use node.state
when we um
get these valid moves right here and
then here we can multiply the SPG policy
with the valid moves as the scale of
over node and then again we want to
divide it by its one sum
like this
so now we can get the item yeah I
believe I think this
doesn't do a big difference here
um yeah because this already is a number
array so I believe we don't need this
actually
so now first of all we want to expand
our node using this SPG policy right
here
then also we want to back propagate here
so I will just copy this over here oh
sorry
um copy this over from here
and we want to back propagate using SPG
dot value
okay so this is great
so basically with this implementation we
have the Monte colored research code
working for this number of parallel
games now at the end we would get these
action props right here
but I believe this is not that helpful
in server ircts class because here we
and you have our
we have this parallelized and this is
how to parallelize these action props
right here so red that we just copy this
out
and
instead we want to work with our action
props instead of OSF Planet method here
so I would just paste
this over to this part here
so because of that we also don't get any
action process return here but we just
change this Visa play games that we
passed on here right
okay so this is great and now let's also
just run this hook to make sure that we
don't have any direct arrows okay so
torch is not defined but that's just
because I haven't run these sets above
so let's just have quickly do that here
[Music]
so let's check whether we got any error
Okay so
okay this is working for now
okay so now we want to update this part
here below and then we are finished with
this parallel implementation
so after we have done this paralyzed
MCTS search we again want to look over
all of our self-play games right so we
can just write for I in range of Len of
s p games
and here remember that we want to remove
the self-play games from our list if
they are terminal right and it's a bit
yeah it's quite bad to remove uh yeah
safely game from a list and then keep
iterating over it from basically zero to
the Len
um because yeah then we would
yeah basically not have a perfect
alignment between this index here and
yeah the actual safe play game we want
to reach if we mutate our list instead
of our Loop right so we can fix this by
uh flipping this range here around okay
so now we want to Loop over this flipped
range of our safe play games right and
then we can just tap all of these things
in right here and
the first thing we want to do is that we
actually want to get this safe play game
at the given position so let's just
write SVG equals self-play games at the
position of I
and then when we get our action props
here we don't want to Loop over the root
of children directly but rather SPG dot
root or children like this
so yeah this should be working
and yeah so then we have this action
props right here
and we don't want to add this just to
the general memory but rather to the
memory of our Circle again this way
and we don't want
this yeah when we call the neutral state
we can just either reference this one or
just the state of the root note
um for our circular games which is right
SPG dot root dot State like this to get
this Nutri state
and then we have these action props here
this should be working fine and then we
have this player right here so then we
also get this temperature action props
and we get this action right here so
this is all working well and now we want
to update the state and here we again
want to call it spg.state so that we
update the state instead of our SPG
class
and we want to update this by first of
all having the Old State so spg.state
right here
and
then by just having this action right
here and having this player right here
so I think this is also fine
and now we get this value and it's
terminated by save the game look at the
terminal and again we have to call
spg.state instead of here
and now we check whether a instrument is
true so here we don't need to Define
this written memory like I said
but rather when we Loop over our memory
first of all we have to declare set this
to SPG dot memory
and then we want to append this to this
General Regional memory that we have
defined up here right
so then we can just
delete this Return part right here and
yeah so this is uh that's something that
we have finished inside here and then we
want to flip the player
um yeah after we have looped over all of
ourself play games and at the end we
just want to return this return memory
appear above
and also I just noticed that when we
um yeah are finished right here with
this play game so if our safe play games
terminal then we also want to delete it
from our list of soft play games right
so that this while loop here it's
working so here we can just write the
and then SP gains if the position of I
so yeah this way we just shorten our
safe play games list and because we Loop
in this other direction it will still
work to just keep looping instead of our
for Loop
um yeah because we will basically just
remove the circle again at this site
when we look in this direction right and
we also have to change this MCTS to MCTS
or parallel here
right oh and I also notice that we have
this Arrow right here where we return
these action props so obviously we want
to remove that line right here because
we just want to return the return memory
and this second was the part of the
Monte Carlo research that we removed and
so let's just run this again and now we
can try to train our model for Connect 4
using this parallelized fs0
implementation let's write F0 parallel
instead of here
and yeah everything else can just stay
the same and I believe now the speed
should be up by about 5x so this should
be a massive Improvement so let's just
run this cell again and we get this nice
progress bar so I will just train this
for these eight iterations here and yeah
this will still take a few hours on my
machine but after that we will have this
a great model that has a very good
understanding of how to play the game of
Connect Four and then we can first of
all evaluate it again and maybe also
play against it in this nice visual way
and maybe we will lose against it so
we'll see
okay so now I've trained in a network
using this IFA zero parallel class for
eight iterations right here uh yeah on
the game of Connect Four
so this still took a few hours I believe
we could have been even faster if we
would have further increased this number
of parallel games here but still that's
fine
and so now we want to test this here
instead of our evaluation set
so first of all let's um change the path
uh your for our weights to model 7
connect 4. right since we trained for
eight iterations
and then next we can also set number of
searches to 600 years where so yeah we
copy this yeah value from the arguments
above
and yeah this is still quite a small
number when you would compare to other
search algorithms that I use in practice
so let's check whether we get nice
results here so let's run the cell
and
oh sorry I've accidentally
accidentally ran this one right here
um so let's run this right here
so now we get this Connect Four board
and I believe we want to play in the
middle right here
so let's see where the model plays and
the model plate on top of it
think we want to play on this side right
here
yeah I think that should be fine
so let's play on the phone
[Music]
um yeah the model plate here I think we
either want to play here or there or
maybe there
so I would just put some pressure on the
model by playing Neon 5.
[Music]
so
now I think
I think we're doing fine when we play
here we just have to be careful so let's
plan for
[Music]
so now we could also pressure
here and then our Motor Company here
right because someone could defend this
so I think
well probably I would want to play
here
[Music]
um
so
if again
sorry I'm very bad at this
yeah probably yeah would have been much
better I guess to play anymore
[Music]
um
so
now we can't play here anymore we could
still play here or there I think this is
valuable here
so
let's move on top of you know this
position here so let's make it three
so we'll multiply it here
um we want to get it we have some
pressure here so maybe we'd like to
clear here we also the same here so
play on two I guess
oh no then if we play here our model
will play here and we would be trapped
so we can't play as well anymore
um
so maybe we could play here but that's
not that good either
um
maybe that's fine here
it's not too valuable
so yes we put it here
okay so where did the model play so just
play it here
Okay so
thing we have to definitely play here I
don't know if we still lose them
and since play on five now
[Music]
okay so where did the play now
um there's some pressure here or so oh
we lost this way and we're also this way
okay we can absolutely destroy it
um yeah I don't know we have to just
just play the three now I guess and yeah
took this right here and yes won the
game because of that so nice uh I could
have even played here as well
um so that should be yeah just I mean I
played quite in a bad way I guess but so
it was super nice and so now we could
see that even though we have around 600
searches our model was still able to at
least destroy me here in this game so
this is fun and
before we conclude with this tutorial
here this is some minor mistakes I
noticed
um so first of all when we get these
temperature action props in fs03 we
currently aren't using them for our
probabilities so let's change that right
here
and so now let's use them here and then
also when we use our Optimizer whether
we're gonna whether we want to call it
safe.optimizer because then we yeah
go for this Optimizer here instead of
just um yeah calling this Optimizer
right which might not work on All
Occasions yeah so that's just a smart
thing let's also add that to this iPhone
0 parallel so
temperature action props here and then
save.optimizer in our Training Method
um okay so now we can just lastly let
our model play with itself and you know
let's also get this nicer form of
visualization compared to just printing
out the spot state right here so yeah
this is what we will do next and here I
want to use the Kegel environments
package so we'll just write import Kegel
environments right here then you know
let's also print out the version so
maybe you're interested in that
um like this
so yeah that's my version right here
and then using this package we can first
of all create an environment and we get
this by setting nth equal to Kegel
environments
dot make and then here we can just use
connect X to get this standard Connect
Four environment I mean this also
tweakable so but here we just get the
standard connector environment and then
next we would want to have some players
so this should just be a list of our
agents and then next we could just say
enter run using these players we have
defined and then end dot render
with mode being equal to IPython instead
of our Jupiter notebook here
so now we also want to Define our
players right so here I've just created
this agent class yeah and I've copied it
over right here so basically we just do
some pre-processing with this date and
then we will yeah just call our MCTS
much search either or just get a
prediction straight up from our model
depending on our arguments so basically
doing something similar than what we do
up here in this Loop right
okay so yeah now we want to create these
players as Kegel agents and before we do
that we also need this model this game
and these arguments right here so we
just copy them over
um from here basically
like this
and then let's paste them yep
[Music]
so first of all we have our game of
Connect Four then we don't need a player
here
um then we also have to add some
arguments right here so first of all we
want to search set search to true
um and then we also need a temperature
and the way this is built up here when
we have temperature equal to zero we
don't uh do this yeah division to get
our
um yeah updated policy but rather we
would just get the arc mix directly so
let's just set temperature to zero right
here so that we always get the arc Max
of our policy
and well the MCTS distribution Guided by
our model
okay so now we have this right here
let's also set the reflect Epsilon to
one so that we still have some
Randomness here
and so next we have our device right
here we create our model like this and
then we use this path right here so this
should be fine so now we can
actually Define our players so let's set
player one equal to calculated agent
and like I said we first find it this
model this game and these arguments so
let's write model game and arcs just
like this so let's let's also do the
same thing for player 2.
so I mean
so this way we have more flexibility if
we would want to try different players
and then here for the players we can
just fill this list with first of all
setting player Wonder run and then
player 2. run like this okay so this
should be working now let's just run the
cell and
um get these nice visualizations
also now we get this neat animation of
our models playing against each other so
we have two players but just one model
here playing against itself basically
and I believe this should come to a draw
yeah so
uh what it is that advanced I guess that
it can defend against all attacks so in
this uh just this nice animation and
now we can also just yeah briefly do the
same for Tic-tac-toe as well so here we
just have to change some small things so
first of all oh sorry
we have to set the game to tic-tac-toe
and event also
um yeah we can change the arguments so
let's just set number of searches to 100
and here went for our resnet we can set
the number of rest blocks to four and
the hidden them to 64 I guess
so then we want to update this path so I
think the last particular terminal we
trade was model 2.pt
if I'm not mistaken so then also here we
have to set this to tick tock towards
way and then we can just run this
okay so now we get this nice animation
immediately of our modest plugins
playing against each other and again we
have gotten a draw because yeah the
model is able to defend all possible
attacks
um so this is still very nice so feel
free to do some further experiments uh
yeah your own so maybe you could also
set the search to fault so that just
your neural networks directly will play
against each other without doing these
hundred searches in this case and yeah
so I think we're finished with this
tutorial this was a lot of fun and
um I've created this GitHub repository
where there's yeah there's a jupyter
notebook store for each checkpoint and
then also um I have this weights folder
where we have the last model for
Tic-tac-toe and the last model for
Connect Four that we have trained
and if any questions feel free to ask
them either in the comments or just by
sending an email for example
and yeah I might do a follow-up video on
mu zero since I've also built that
algorithm from scratch so if you're
interested in that so
um would be nice to let me know so thank
you